Moin, da bin ich.
Was ist das für ein Emote, das kenne ich gar nicht.
Wusste gar nicht, dass ich das aktiviert habe.
Hab ich das aktiviert oder ist das irgendwie ein Personal Emote von dir?
Find ich gar nicht übel.
Ich glaube es ist ein Personal Emote von dir.
Ich hab das noch nie gesehen.
So, Sound mal kurz checken.
Ob Teams wieder irgendwas verkackt hat.
Achso, hört man mich?
Gut.
Ja, weil das letzte Mal hab ich ja geschwätzt, 10 Minuten lang und ihr habt mich nicht gehört.
Personal, ja, dachte ich mir, ok, Sound passt, exellent, exellent.
Ja Leute, ich muss heute ein bisschen entspannter sprechen mit euch, ja.
Etwas ruhiger, entspannter, weil mir tut wieder der Hals weh, war jetzt ein paar Wochen lang
richtig gut.
Aber seit ein, zwei Tagen tut mir der Hals wieder ein bisschen weh und ich will nicht,
dass es wieder, äh, so beschissen wird wie es letztes Mal war, 50 Minuten bis, bis was,
was für ein Ding?
Ach du, ja ok, ich glaube jetzt weiß ich was du meinst, ich muss mal kurz, du meinst,
du meinst dieses Gerichtsverfahren mit, mit, mit Dings, mit Johnny Depp?
Ach so, ja da muss ich jetzt mal kurz, kurz in mich, ja ganz ehrlich, das geht mir voll
am Arsch vorbei, ich interessiere mich für solche Celebrity Geschichten, absolut gar
nicht.
Ich mein, gut, das ist jetzt als weniger darum, ob das jetzt irgendwelche bekannten Schauspieler
sind, sondern eher, so die eigentliche Sache, die die Leute in dem Fall interessieren,
wobei auch, auch, ja, wenn jetzt irgendwie, äh, Nachbar um die Ecke sich, äh, dann wird
auch keinen interessieren.
Abofalle, ja, Pock, so muss das sein, ne, aber das interessiert mich überhaupt nicht.
Ich bekomme, ich bekomme Laufe, aber ich dachte, der hat ihn immer auf den Tisch gehauen, warum
sollte ihm der Hals davon weh tun, ähm, was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen, fuck, ich hab
gerade zu sehr auf einen anderen Bildschirm geguckt, ach so, ja, man bekommt ja laufend
irgendwelche Videos von empfohlen, ich hab auch ein paar mal Kleinigkeiten geguckt, aber
das hat mich so überhaupt nicht interessiert, aber ich interessiere mich für so Celebrity
Sachen auch absolut gar nicht.
Danke für die Subs, Leute, Jis Jix, Jis Jix, Leon, Pock Zapp, jo, also wie gesagt, muss
ich mich ein bisschen zusammenreißen, ich muss mit euch heute, äh, entspannt und, äh,
ASMR Style reden und immer schön was trinken, dass mir der Hals nicht weiter weh tut, ich
hab mir jetzt sogar schon, komm mir langsam vor wie der, wie der, wie der riesen Opa,
ich hab mir sogar so ein Inhalationsgerät auf Amazon gekauft, dass man dann irgendwie
mit so einer Ladung 10 Minuten, äh, Salz, Salzwasser, Dampf inhalieren kann, weil das
wohl gegen trockenen Hals und sonst was hilft, es hilft auch ein bisschen was, aber, ich
war ja wie gesagt, ich war ja auch schon mal im HNO, als so wirklich rausgekommen ist
ja da nix, so, tja, im Prinzip wie Kopium, ja, nur dass ich das selbst halten muss und
nicht umgeschnallt hab.
Also, das sieht aus, sieht aus wie das Kopium-Emote, genau, eigentlich geiler Vergleich, hätt
ich jetzt überhaupt nicht dran gedacht, aber ja, das trifft's gut, so, ach ja, warum haben
wir Kopium eigentlich nicht aktiviert als Emote?
Muss ich mal kurz nachholen, Kopium, Max, hast du meinen Kommentar ernst genommen?
Welchen?
Du hast doch gar nix geschrieben, außer LOL, oder meinst du diesen Kommentar hier jetzt?
Ach so, nee, hab ich nicht gesehen, ich hab aber auch die letzten, letzte halbe Stunde
oder so nicht mehr reingeguckt auf YouTube.
Wisst ihr, was mir gerade einfällt, der Karsten, also so Real Life-Kollege vom Friseur und
mir, der hat früher immer gesagt, das heißt nicht YouTube, sondern U2B, und der Karsten
hat meistens Ahnung wovon er spricht, dankeschön Michael, 50 Billionen, Massive Q-Chat, aber
ich mein, das heißt YouTube, da sind wir uns einig in dem Fall, aber der hat immer gesagt,
U2B, nee, man wird nicht aufgemacht, man wird vielleicht eingeschlafen, kann auch sein.
Du hast mit Keqvee kommentiert, wirklich, Moment, das muss ich jetzt überprüfen, ja,
ich habe Keq, hab ich Keqvee kommen, das ist mal, ich antworte manchmal auf Comments ohne
richtig was mir das, also das geht nicht durchs normale Gehirn durch, das nimmt so extra
Weg, gerade wenn es Twitch-Emotes sind, Sneakflavor, danke für den Sub, zeig mal her, wo habe
ich Keqvee?
Das da?
Nee, das ist der Tainsaw, den hab ich schon eine Weile hier gesehen, zeig mal her, ich
hab hier drauf geantwortet, hier, Keqvee hab ich drauf geantwortet, ja Moment, tatsächlich
ich hab drauf geantwortet und das ist erst 13 Minuten her, tja, siehst du mal, hab ich
das gar nicht richtig, dann hab ich tatsächlich nicht vor einer halben Stunde, sondern vor
13 Minuten zuletzt in YouTube reingeguckt und deinen Comment da drauf hab ich nicht
mehr gesehen, ist schon, Keq, Keqvee ist quasi so, bei mir ohne Gehirnleistung möglich wie
einsen copypasten, weißt du, irgendjemand schreibt was, ich muss das gar nicht lesen,
Keqvee, Lul geht auch, weil wir wissen ja, dass Lul größer, größer Lul ist, allerdings
ich bin mir nicht sicher, chat, jetzt in Anbetracht der Tatsache, ja, ich mein die Voraussetzungen
sind ja ähnlich, beides sind lange Zeit die ultimativen Lach-Emotes gewesen, also Lul
oder Keqvee, ja, und beide sind tot mittlerweile, also sowohl TotalBiscuit als auch El Resitas,
die sind beide, die sind beide schon gestorben, leider, jetzt mal in Anbetracht der Tatsache,
dass das jetzt ja beides wirklich einschneidende Emotes sind, was sagt ihr, was ist das ultimative
Twitch, also es gibt nur diese zwei zur Auswahl, was ist das ultimative Twitch, also ehrlich
gesagt, die richtet das richtig originale, das richtig originale ist ja auch Lul und
nicht das nachgemachte, aber fassen wir mal Lul und Lul zusammen, was ist das ultimative
Twitch Lach-Emote, Keqvee oder Lul, was sagt ihr, ich ändere da eigentlich fast wöchentlich
meine Meinung, ich tendiere so overall zu Lul, aber von dem, was ich öfters benutze, ist
es Keqvee, das heißt, ich bin mir, Lulvee ist natürlich auch gut, aber das zähl ich
mal zu Lul dabei, okay Keqvee, ja das ist, das ist witzig, ich mag, ich mag Lul eigentlich
als Emote mehr, aber ich verwende Keqvee häufiger, was eigentlich keinen Sinn ergibt, weil man
ja davon ausgehen würde, dass man das Emote, was man mehr mag, auch öfters verwendet,
aber das muss man nicht verstehen, das ist das übrig gebliebene Zoomer hier in mir,
habt ihr mein Video von heute geguckt, ja, es gibt, es kennst du Lul, ne, es gibt wenige
älteres Videos in letzter Zeit, das Keqvee, oh man, das ist quasi Emote Rickrolling, wenn
man das so will, ja, das ist Emote Rickrolling, ja, also Chat, ich hab paar Themen, die wir
uns die nächsten Streams unbedingt angucken müssen, aber ich hatte in den letzten Tagen
wenig Zeit, wir müssen uns unbedingt angucken, also was, was ich mir schon eine Weile angucken
will ist ein bisschen WebAssembly Zeug, einfach, dass ich mal ein bisschen Ahnung hab, wahrscheinlich
mit Rust, dann müssen wir noch ein bisschen an der Monitoring-Geschichte weiter programmieren,
äh, programmieren, was erzähl ich denn, weiter, weiter basteln und ich muss noch was
für ein Fernsehen machen, aber das erzähl ich euch dann, wenn es soweit ist, dass wir
eine Analoge, ähm, Fernsehtechnik, fuck up, abfuck, nicht fuck up, abfuck, der Labelchamp,
den hab ich ganz vergessen, ja, das Ding steht hier bei mir rum und geht nicht, das muss
auch noch fertig gemacht werden, ja, tatsächlich, ne, der ist nicht tot, den muss ich fertig
machen, ich hab mir nicht umsonst dieses Gerät gekauft, zumal der Labelchamp eigentlich fast
schon funktional ist, der ist eigentlich zu, sag mal mal, 70-80% fertig, ähm, und wisst
ihr wie ich auf das Thema WebAssembly gekommen bin, dass ich mir das unbedingt mal angucken
muss, ich hab mir überlegt, ob man nicht, ähm, Videos im Browser abspielen kann, in
Sachen, die nicht vom Browser supportet werden, also im Prinzip, was wird vom Browser supportet
an Videos, WebM, A264, Codec, ähm, ich glaub das war's zum größten Teil, oder, so, und
dann hab ich gesehen, ne, die ToDo-App war doch nur zum üben, du meinst, du meinst
CACW as a Service, ach ne, du meinst diese andere ToDo-App, wo, ja Moment, die ToDo-App,
die haben wir, die haben wir doch, die haben wir doch nur gebaut zum üben von's Welt damals,
das war ToDo-App, niemand braucht die ToDo-App, das war einfach, ToDo-App gibt's 30 Milliarden
im Internet, ne, das war einfach nur zum üben, ja, und dann hab ich, dann hab ich Folgendes
gefunden auf GitHub, FFmpeg, Wasm, ja, irgendwelche verrückten Leute haben FFmpeg, äh, cross-compiled,
so dass es jetzt über WebAssembly im Browser läuft, es ist mittlerweile, ich sag euch,
Browser sind eigene Betriebssysteme, mittlerweile, und es kommen so viele coole Entwicklungen
noch für Browser, wo man halt echt sagen muss, das ist quasi fast schon egal mittlerweile,
was man für einen Unterbau hat, Hauptsache es gibt einen Browser, ja, zum Beispiel, das
neueste was angesagt ist in Browsern ist, ja, also Hype ist aktuell ziemlich WebAssembly,
dann ist WebGPU voll angesagt aktuell, es gibt noch kaum Browser-Unterstützung, aber
das ist so, im Kommen, das ist quasi noch mal eine Stufe tiefer als WebGL, dann gibt
es WebCodecs, gibt es noch, was dann besseres Video-Rendering im Browser macht, es gibt
so viele, es gibt so viele Sachen, ja, und wisst ihr, wisst ihr was das, was das Bittere
dabei ist, wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt, so can I use, und ihr gebt mal irgendwas,
ein irgendwas halbwegs modernes, keine Ahnung, WebCodecs, ich weiß, weiß gar nicht ob man
hier was nehmen kann, kann man hier gar nicht suchen, zumindest, ihr werdet feststellen,
wenn ihr irgendwas halbwegs modernes sucht, Safari supportet den Scheiß immer nicht,
also ganz ehrlich, Safari ist der schlimmste Browser und noch, Safari ist der neue Internet-Explorer,
ja, und noch schlimmer, warte mal, was hatte ich denn heute Morgen, ja, es gab ja mal sowas
wie Media Extensions zum Beispiel, sowas wie Media Extensions gab es ja mal, das war
so ein Versuch Video-Playback zu machen, aber hat sich nicht so wirklich durchgesetzt, weil
ihr seht es, im Endeffekt, es unterstützt zu jeder Browser, Safari war ein bisschen
langsamer, aber, was unterstützt es nicht, eine ganz wichtige Plattform, Safari und iOS
unterstützt es nicht, und das hier steht unterstützt ist debated, wirklich unterstützt
wird das ganze nur von, auf dem iPad, nicht auf dem iPhone, also es ist schlimm, Safari
ist der neue Internet-Explorer, ich mein, sogar so Sachen wie WebP und sowas, brauchen
die ewig, oder WebM Unterstützung hatten die beispielsweise auch ewig nicht, jetzt guckt
euch das mal an, WebM ist Standard, das ist ewig schon, ihr müsst euch das mal angucken,
die erste Unterstützung gab es in Chrome 6, in Chrome 6, das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen,
den ersten Partialsupport gab es in Chrome 6 und in Firefox 4, aber Safari denkt sich
so, ne, das brauchen wir nicht, und das, wenn ihr hier guckt, das ist übrigens auch der
default WebRTC-Codec, was natürlich nochmal doppelt dumm ist, wenn das Safari nicht kann,
so, mittlerweile ist es halt in Safari so, Safari kann es theoretisch, aber es ist hinter
einem Config-Switch versteckt, und niemand schaltet das an, außer er hat eine eigene
Anwendung, die es braucht, und will das machen, also du kannst nicht was im App-Store veröffentlichen,
was da drauf setzt oder so, weil im Prinzip, nachdem es ja nur Safari gibt unter iOS, es
gibt ja kein, es gibt ja nicht wirklich, es gibt zwar die App, die so heißt, aber ist
es nicht, es gibt ja nicht wirklich Chrome und Firefox unter iOS, das ist ja alles Safari
reprended, sind natürlich auch die Webviews, die man in der Anwendung hat, letztendlich
Safari, und wenn Safari irgendwas nicht kann, dann kann das das auch im Webview nicht, zumal
Webview in der Regel noch deutlich restriktiver ist als die richtige Safari-App, auch ganz,
ganz bitteres, Progressive-Web-Apps, gibt's wieder nicht, Notification, weiß ich, Web-Notifications,
gibt's wieder nicht, warum, warum gibt es die coolen Sachen immer nicht auf Safari und
gerade auf Safari iOS, das ist so ein Abfuck, ich mein, die wissen genau, dass es eigentlich
unmöglich ist, was rauszubringen, was nicht auch Safari iOS berücksichtigt, außer man
möchte halt irgendwie Millionen an Kunden außen vor lassen, das will natürlich keiner,
jemand, der eine Web-Service rausbringt oder eine App dafür rausbringt oder eine App rausbringt,
der muss auf, ich mein, heute sind 80% der User bei so was auf Mobilgeräten unterwegs
und das meiste ist für Android, aber ein Riesenteil ist auch iOS, ja, aber das gleiche könnte
man, das gleiche könnte man ja bei Android auch sagen und Android ist da besser, Android
unterstützt den meisten Krämpel und sogar Web-Notifications, Android Chrome und solche
Sachen, also das funktioniert, der Preis-Champ, der konnte zum Beispiel unter, also als es
ihn noch gab, konnte der Preis-Champ, wenn eine Grafikkarte in deiner angegebenen Price-Range
drinne war, konnte der dir eine Notification schicken, das ging aber nur auf dem Desktop
oder auf Android, das ging nicht an Safari, weil Apple sich denkt, Moment, das benutze
ich selten, aber das muss man jetzt mal machen, Apple denkt sich, genau das denkt sich Apple
beim Support von Safari, Keyukon, lange nicht gesehen, ja, schön, dass du wieder da bist,
28 Monate, Samuel, danke für 7 Monate Subscription, was ich so spät mache, ich streben jetzt
bis 22 Uhr und dann gehe ich ins Bett gehen, tja, ja, aber die hätten doch, das was ich
meine, die hätten ja prinzipiell die gleiche Motivation dahinter wie Apple, aber sie machen
es nicht, dafür macht, dafür macht Google etwas andere, fragwürdige Sachen, ja, zum
Beispiel, mal gucken, wie es hier aussieht, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr auch schon die Ehre
habt, gucken wir mal, ob es hier auch so ist, nee, hier sieht es noch normal aus, hier sieht
es in dem Firefox aus, probieren wir es, wir machen einfach mal ein paar Browser auf und
gucken uns das an, what the fuck, warum sieht das so ästlich aus, also hier habe ich es
noch nicht, hat jemand von euch schon die neue, die neue Navigationsleiste oder diese
neue Video, nicht Navigation, den neuen Videotitel auf YouTube, guck, wie beschissen das aussieht,
hier, guck mal, das ist neu, was ist das, also jetzt mal, jetzt mal seriously, wer, welcher
Low IQ Designer hat er sich gedacht, das ist eine gute Idee, vor allem, ich meine, was
ist das denn bitte für eine Usability, was ist das für eine Usability, mach die Kommentare
rechts, wer zum Geier will so Kommentare lesen, wer will so ernsthaft, seriously, wer will
so, wie beschissen, alter, wer will so Kommentare lesen, man, und wisst ihr, was das, was das
verdächtige ist, wenn YouTube sowas macht, die pushen gerne solche Changes und nach einem
dreiviertel Jahr oder so wird das Standard, also ganz ehrlich, wer will diesen Scheiß
als Standard haben, ja, und ich glaube, tatsächlich, also ich könnte mir das wirklich vorstellen,
dass YouTube irgendwann, ich glaube es nicht wirklich, aber ich könnte es mir irgendwie
vorstellen, dass YouTube die Kommentare abschafft und dann auch mit der Begründung, die Leute
sollen sich safe fühlen oder sowas, das ist ja die neue ultimative Begründung, die mittlerweile
überall rausgehauen wird und irgendwie aus mir nicht verständlichen Gründen auch überall
gelten gelassen wird, ja, auch wenn es damit gar nichts zu tun hat, so nach dem Motto, das
ist alles so negativ, die Leute könnten sich da gekränkt fühlen, da fühlen sich die Leute
nicht safe in den Kommentaren, deswegen schaffen wir die Kommentare ab, ja, anstatt das Kommentarsystem
weiter zu verbessern, nein, schafft man sie dann im Zweifelsfall ab, es ist genauso wie
mit den Videobewertungen, wo ja auch erzählt wurde, die Videobewertungen werden abgeschafft,
dass keiner Hate-Bewertung abgibt und sowas, sowas bescheuertes, Alter, und das Schlimme
ist, dass du das heute überhaupt so argumentieren kannst und dass die Leute dann auch noch
fressen und das glauben, dabei ist es so offensichtlich, dass das irgendeine Marketing-Stonks-Geld-Money-Entscheidung
ist, als würde es ernsthaft YouTube irgendwie interessieren, ob sich da irgendeiner, die
persönlichen Gefühle der Leute interessiert, YouTube doch nicht die Bode, wenn die das
interessieren würden, dann hätten sie zum Beispiel bessere psychologische Betreuung
für ihre, genauso wie bei Facebook, für ihre Content-Kontrolleure, die das nicht länger
als ein halbes Jahr machen können und teilweise sich schon umgebracht haben, weil sie sich
den ganzen kranken Scheiß angucken müssen, die die Leute hochladen.
Das ist einzig und allein eine Stonks-Geld-Entscheidung gewesen, die Kommentare abzuschaffen, deswegen
kann ich euch nur empfehlen, Leute, was ist was, was möchte, was, warum war da eben kein
anderes Symbol oben? Chat, wart ihr das? Wer ist es gewesen? Wer hat das andere Symbol
da gerade oben hingemacht? Die Hacker-Mans im Chat waren's wieder. Weiß war's, ne, wer
war's denn jetzt? Jetzt Chat, gebt euch zu erkennen, wer ist es gewesen? Ich glaub ja
Kyokon war das. Der war so lang nicht da. Was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Ja, deswegen kann
ich euch nur empfehlen, wenn ihr, ich kann nicht mal meinen, ich kann noch nicht mal
meinen eigenen Namen schreiben, ja. Wenn ihr auf YouTube seid und dann zum Beispiel auf
meinen Channel geht, ihr müsst, Return YouTube Dislikes, oder ne, wie heißt dieses Addon
überhaupt? Return YouTube Dislikes müsst ihr euch installieren. Das ist erstaunlich
akkurat. Soll ich euch mal sagen, wie genau das ist? Soll ich mal kurz reingucken bei
mir? Also wie gesagt, ich bin hier nicht eingeloggt, ne, also normalerweise kann ich das nicht
sehen. Das ist erstaunlich akkurat. Ich sag's euch mal, wie genau das ist. Achso, fuck,
wo sieht man diese Bewertung überhaupt jetzt? Ja, ich hab 1037 Daumen hoch und neun Daumen
runter und das Plugin hat das quasi, obwohl es das gar nicht sehen kann, auf acht geschätzt.
Das ist nicht schlecht. Obwohl das Plugin halt total versagt, geh ich mal von aus, vermute
ich, rate ich jetzt mal, ist, wenn du einen Channel hast, der so das Like Dislike Verhältnis
hat von meinem und der lädt dann auf einen Schlag was super kontroverses rauf und es
entspricht überhaupt nicht mehr so dem, was ihr Algorithmus gelernt hat über diesen Channel,
dann könnte es wahrscheinlich komplett nebendran liegen. Ich mein, die machen ja mehrere Sachen
in diesem Addon, das beschreiben die hier auch irgendwo, was sie genau machen, um die
Dislikes zu errechnen. Also die haben ein, einfach ein soziales Experiment. Schminkvideo
mit dem Friseur steht eh noch aus, ja, seit 50 Jahren. So, die haben ja, weiß ich, ob
sie hier irgendwas erklären, wo sie das machen. How does it work? Genau. Also, ja gut, das
ist natürlich sehr, ja. Also, die Leute sharen das. Die Leute, die eingeloggt sind, diese
Extension installiert haben, die können das mit sharen und die machen das aus historischen
Daten fest und im Hintergrund Auswertung, Comment, View, Ratio und sowas, Like zu Comments, Likes
zu Views und so. Aber man sieht insgesamt, das funktioniert nicht schlecht, das kommt
gut hin. Es liegt nur ein Dislike daneben. Ja, normalerweise würde ich sagen, ja, okay,
bei meinem ist es jetzt besonders korrekt gewesen, aber ich denke mal, so ungefähr wird es bei
anderen Videos auch stimmen, ja. Es ist doch jetzt egal, ob ein Video 50 Dislikes hat oder
250 Dislikes hat, wenn das so im Verhältnis ungefähr stimmt. Wichtig ist, dass man eben
erkennt, welche Videos einfach Schrott sind und welche nichts. Und das ist ja auch mein
Kritikpunkt an diesem Entfernen gewesen, der Dislikes, dass du gerade im Technologiebereich,
wenn du dir Talks anguckst von irgendwelchen Konferenzen, die einfach shit sind oder irgendwelche
indischen Tutorial-Videos hast, wo es eigentlich kaum ums Thema geht oder irgendwas, was ich
auch geil finde. Manchmal, kennt ihr diese Videos, da steht da irgendwie so, keine Ahnung,
how to frontend development, Vue.js, bla, bla, bla, wie man was macht. Dann klickst
du das Video an, auf einmal redet dann einer Indisch. Also Moment, also dieser Titel ist
definitiv nicht einfach nur, weil das die ähnlichen englischen Wörter sind, sondern
weil er es explizit auf Englisch geschrieben hat. Das verwirrt mich dann auch immer. Du
hast ein Video, komplett englischen Titel, mit genau dem Problem, was du hast und hast
so ein Inder im Video, wo du nichts verstehst. Und dann ist wichtig, dass man sowas direkt
erkennen kann. Gut, mein Inder erkennst du gleich, den verstehst du nicht, aber gerade
Konferenz-Talks und Tutorials ist das wichtig, dass man Dislikes hat, weil ansonsten erkennst
du schlicht und ergreifend nicht. Ich guck mir doch nicht eine Stunde einen Konferenz-Talk
an, um dann vielleicht bei der Hälfte festzustellen, da kommt jetzt nichts Interessantes. Das fing
gern zu Indisch, das ist ein Fivehead, so vorbildlich. So sollte man das machen. Boah,
Leute, mir fällt gerade noch Sache ein. Ich sag euch aber gleich, das gucken wir uns nicht
im Stream zusammen, man. Ich hab letztens ein ultra Fremdschirm-Video gesehen auf YouTube,
nicht meins, nicht meins, könnte auch so sein, aber ich hab ein Video gesehen von irgendeinem,
von der ARD oder so, weiß ich gar nicht genau. Also es hat irgendeiner von Funk auf jeden
Fall produziert und da haben sie so zwei Twitter-Eltern, so zwei empörte Twitter-Eltern begleitet
einen Tag lang mit ihrem Kind. Alter, diese Leute waren so fertig. Die waren so fertig,
das war richtig cringe, Alter, ich konnte mir das kaum angucken. Das Kind ist irgendwie
zwei oder drei oder glaub ich jetzt, nee, nee, ich glaub vier mittlerweile und es legit,
pass mal auf, die durfte, das Kind durfte keine normalen Kinderbücher lesen, sondern
musste Kinderbücher lesen wie My Little Feminist Family und so was. Und da hab ich auch gedacht,
what the fuck, Alter, was ist mit euch los? Oh no, ja. Ich dachte erst ohne Scheiß, als
ich das gesehen hab, als ich das gesehen hab, ich dachte erst, das ist ein Witz, ja, also
ich dachte, das ist im Endeffekt Satire, so könnte man sagen, ist es aber nicht, die
meinen das wirklich ernst. Ja, ach du hast das auch geguckt, ja. Jaja, genau, das Kind,
das Kind, das ohne Gender erzogen wird. Alter, das war so cringe, meine Güte, die Leute
waren auch noch so überzeugt davon. Ich hab nur Schwierigkeiten, das durchzuhalten. Ja,
genau, die hab ich ja auch an, deswegen seh ich das ja auch. Übrigens, wisst ihr, wisst
ihr, wer wieder geschrieben hat? Ihr werdet es kaum glauben, mehrfach, mehrfach. Zwei
Sachen, ratet mal, ratet mal zwei Sachen, die mir wieder Sponsoranfragen geschrieben
haben, zwei Sachen, zwei verschiedene Sachen. Wahrscheinlich kommt ihr drauf, weil es ist
ziemlich offensichtlich. Raid, ja, Raid ist das eine, Raid, Raid, korrekt, korrekt, und
das NordVPN, du, Major Laser, du hast erraten, NordVPN und Raid Shadow Legends, korrekt.
Und witzigerweise, Raid Shadow Legends ist mega hartnäckig, die schreiben mich gerade
mit vier, von vier unterschiedliche Leute an. Vier unterschiedliche Leute. Also, haben
die alle Werbeagenturen der Welt beauftragt oder was? Quatsch, ich mach mit denen nix.
Das ist Schwachsinn, die Jugend wird nicht den Bach runtergehen. Die aktuelle Jugend
ist mehr Five Head, als man sich das vorstellen kann. Deswegen finde ich es immer blöd, wenn
Leute, sagen wir so, in meinem Alter und plus, so tun, als sind alle jungen Leute doof.
Das ist nicht so. Die jungen Leute sind nicht doof. Die jungen Leute sind im Verhältnis
genauso doof und schlau wie die älteren Leute. Ein Faktor gibt es aber. Manche Sachen, da
macht es die Erfahrung auch ein bisschen aus. Zum Beispiel, diese ganzen Scams, komm in
die Gruppe, kauf meine Stonks, du wirst reich, die ganzen Scams, die es überall gibt. Ich
glaube, manchmal muss man einfach, da muss ein paar Jahre ins Land gezogen sein, vielleicht
muss man auch schon mal gescampt worden sein und dann lernt man es vielleicht früher oder
später, dass wenn die Leute versprechen, sie machen dich reich und nur sie wissen,
wie das geht, dass das in der Regel nur zum besten dieser Leute ist und nicht für dich
selbst. Das ist wieder was anderes. Die alten Leute fallen auf den Enkeltrick rein oder
solche Dinge. Na gut, es gibt ja auch noch den Handwerkertrick, das ist quasi der Enkeltrick
für etwas Jüngere. Ja, das gibt es schon. Aber gerade so diese Beschisssachen, die es
gibt, auch von Schneeballsystemen und sonst was. Ich glaube, manche Sachen muss der erste
Mal am eigenen Leib erfahren haben oder oft genug das mitbekommen haben, wie es passiert
ist und realisiert haben. Die meisten Leute, die versprechen, dass sie dich reich machen,
wollen dich scammen. Übrigens, wisst ihr, was das erste Mal war, wo ich gescampt wurde?
Nichts Schlimmes. Nichts Schlimmes. Aber wo ich mich richtig krass gescampt gefühlt
habe, mir hat in Diablo 2 einmal einer meine Windforce gescampt in einem Trade. Falls jemand
Diablo 2 gespielt hat, der weiß Windforce ist so ziemlich der beste Bogen im Spiel,
gerade wenn man Amazone spielt und der hat Trade-Window-Trick, was es in fast jedem MMO
oder Action-RPG mit Trade in irgendeiner Weise schon gegeben hat. Also was ist Trade-Window-Trick?
Trade-Window-Trick ist also Trade-Window D2. Ich zeige euch einfach mal was hochaufgelösteres.
Zum Beispiel das Path of Exile Trade-Window. Das sieht fast genauso aus wie das Trade-Window
aus Diablo 2, nur ein bisschen mehr High-Res. Das ist halt ein Trade-Window. Und was passiert
beim Trade-Window-Scam und was man dagegen machen kann? Naja, man tauscht einfach Sachen
aus, die entweder so aussehen, wie die eigentlichen Sachen die man haben will. Ja zum Beispiel
hier tradet einer in Path of Exile einen Stab mit drei Sockel in dieser Farbe. Was jetzt
passieren kann ist, dass der sich das anguckt, drüber geht und sagt ah ist alles okay. Also
der hier, der oben und dann tauscht er den Stab aus gegen einen anderen Stab, der auch
genauso aussieht mit den gleichen Sockel und wenn du dann halt nicht guckst bist du gescammt.
So und sowas in der Richtung ist mir in Diablo 2 auch passiert mit dem ziemlich poggers Bogen.
Ja, Trade-Window-Scam gibt es und das einfachste ist, sobald ihr mitbekommt, dass irgendjemand
in den Trade-Windows, das ist jetzt für alle Spiele mit Trade, wenn einer anfängt rum
zu klicken in den Trade-Windows, bricht den Trade ab. Es gibt keinen Grund, dass du in
diesem Trade-Window die Items 50 mal klicken musst, rein oder raus legen, gibt es nicht.
Der einzige Grund ist Scam und das ist sowas, das lernt man einfach nur durch Erfahrung,
das weiß man noch nicht. Ja, es ist im Prinzip auch wie BitConnect, ich meine ernsthaft,
irgendjemand der BeConnect geguckt hat, war der Meinung, das ist kein Scam und das ist
eine legit Unternehmung, der man Geld geben soll und da frage ich mich jetzt, wer sieht
so ein Video? Also wer guckt sich sowas an? Wer guckt sich sowas an? Es reichen schon
die ersten 10 Sekunden und denkt sich, jawoll, denen gebe ich mein Geld. Wirkt das in irgendeiner
Art und Weise seriös, als sollte ich denen mein Geld geben? So und das haben sich Leute
angeguckt und haben daraufhin gesagt, jawoll, Carlos, nimm meine Kohle. By the way, es hat
sich ja im Nachhinein rausgestellt, die Leute, ich hab's nicht mehr so genau im Kopf, also
nehmt das mal mit einer Portion Skepsis, kann sein, dass ich euch jetzt Mist erzähle, aber
ich bilde mir ein, ich hab sowas mal gelesen, die Leute, die hier auf der Bühne standen
wussten gar nicht um was es geht, das war einfach nur Show, dann stell dich mal auf
die Bühne. So, okay, das reicht jetzt, das reicht jetzt. Wer hat sich gedacht, den
gebe ich mal, wobei, der Typ wurde ja auch gescampt, aber wer hat sich gedacht, kennst
du den Typ mit dem 2 Millionen, ja, das hab ich schon gesehen, da gibt's ein Video von,
gibt's ein Video zu, dieser YouTuber hat fast 2 Millionen Videos veröffentlicht, aber
ich weiß nicht, ob das mal, ob das jetzt noch mal kurz hier abzuschließen, oh ne, der
Insimodus, das ist so dumm, das hab ich mir gemerkt, alter, der Insimodus wurde aktiviert,
das klingt immer noch zu geil, alter, der Insimodus, ich fass es nicht, egal, so, aber um die Sache
abzuschließen, also niemand, der ernsthaft noch seine Tassen alle im Schrank hat und
vielleicht schon mal mitbekommen hat, dass die Leute öfters mal gescampt werden, gerade
mit solchen Sachen, gibt den Leuten oder hat den Leuten von Bitconnect sein Geld gegeben,
das ist das, was ich mein, manchmal brauchst du einfach ein bisschen Erfahrung, weil du
weißt, wenn die Leute versprechen, sie machen dich reich, dann ist es Schwachsinn, hey,
ich sag nicht, dass da keiner drauf reinfällt, aber es ging ja darum, dass alle Boomer, alle
Zoomer doof sind und das ist ja nicht so.
Das ist tatsächlich so, ja, wir haben auch dumme Sachen gemacht und wisst ihr, wisst
ihr was ich mich teilweise frage?
Ich bin letztens an meiner alten Schule vorbeigelaufen und irgendwann Nachmittags und die haben jetzt
einen neuen Parkplatz, früher war das so, da gab es einen Parkplatz vor der Schule,
keine Ahnung, acht Stellplätze oder so, das war im Prinzip für die Lehrer oder wenn
mal irgendwie Nachmittags da einer hin musste oder so, war im Prinzip für die Lehrer und
ansonsten, manchmal wurden die Kinder vorbeigebracht, aber zu 90% sind eigentlich früher die Kinder
immer mit dem Fahrrad gefahren oder in die Schule gelaufen, ja, das war ja auch nicht
weit, aber ich bin letztens bei mir an der Schule vorbeigegangen mittags und die haben
jetzt einen extra Parkplatz, mal kurz Musik an, die haben jetzt einen extra Parkplatz,
weil es morgens zu viel Stress gegeben hat, weil die alle ihre Kinder nicht mehr abliefern
können und da frage ich mich immer so, ich meine, wir haben den Kram überlebt und meine
Oma hat auch irgendwie überlebt, wie haben die das eigentlich gemacht alle, wie haben
wir das überhaupt überlebt, das ist doch eigentlich gar nicht möglich, also müsste
man sich halt denken, ja, also ich meine, ich verstehe beispielsweise nicht, warum du
die Kinder unbedingt mit dem Auto zur Schule fahren musst, ich meine, ich wäre auch gerne
zur Schule gefahren worden, ja, das ist angenehm, es ist angenehm, aber ich meine, du musst
doch nicht bei jedem Schritt und Dritt dabei sein, ja, und also, ist so schlimm, fahre
ich Fahrrad, fahre ich jetzt auch nicht, ja, so ist es, ja, CSGO Skin Trades, das ist genau
so was in der Richtung, doch, ist so, doch, doch, doch, doch, genau das passiert auch
in den Trade Windows, sobald er das Item bewegt, ist er weg, aber du musst dann erneut bestätigen,
aber wenn der Typ das 3, 4 mal rein und raus zieht, dann guckst du vielleicht nicht mal
richtig nach, ja, zumal das ja noch heimtückischer machen kannst, es gibt ja Items, die sind
ultra viel wert, weil sie 2, 3 Stats in der richtigen Kombination haben und dann hast
du was mit vielleicht schlecht gewürfelten Stats, aber den gleichen Stats, was genau
so aussieht und dann guckst du drüber, wenn das wieder hingeht, der Verify Button und
dann guckst du nicht genau auf die Zahl, also Trade Scam is real, mittlerweile versuchen
die Leute, versucht man da ein bisschen vorzubeugen, aber damals wurdest du Diablo 2 quasi die
ganze Zeit versucht zu Trade Windows scammen, im Trade Channel, übrigens, ich hab mir das
Video tatsächlich nochmal angeguckt, wir haben ja letztens nur den Ausschnitt geguckt, wo
ApoRed den Insie Modus aktiviert hat, wobei ich glaube ich hab's zugemacht, boah, was
war das denn, irgendein Musikvideo, ich hab mir das jetzt nochmal angeguckt das Video
und wisst ihr, was ich mir so gedacht habe, ich hab keine Ahnung ob das stimmt, also
erstens hab ich mir dabei gedacht, das ist ganz schön blöd, quasi öffentlich zuzugeben,
dass man den Staat bescheißen will, indem man Privatinsolvenz anmeldet und dann im Ausland
die fette Kohle macht, so, das öffentlich zu sagen ist schonmal blöd, aber wisst ihr
was deutlich wahrscheinlicher ist oder was naheliegender ist, was ich so noch gar nicht
gehört hab, aber was mir sofort eingefallen ist, vielleicht denkt er sich das einfach
nur aus, vielleicht ist es ihm peinlich Insolvenz anmelden zu müssen, das kann ich mir gut
vorstellen, wär's mir auch, vielleicht ist das einfach nur ne Story, dass es nicht so
peinlich wirkt, dass er Insolvenz anmelden muss, dann kann er sowas ja erzählen, also
finde ich witzig, dass das kommt, ja den Anwalt YouTuber haben wir letztes Jahr den Ausschnitt
geguckt, der Insimodus, das ist finde ich die viel naheliegendste Variante, ich mein
der hat schon ein paar doofe Sachen gebracht in der Vergangenheit, aber dass er so unvorsichtig
ist und wenn er dann den Staat da um Geld scammen will und dann sich öffentlich im Video
hinstellt, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, das ist irgendeine Story, weil es ihm peinlich
ist, dass er Insolvent ist, was ich auch voll verstehen kann an der Stelle, also insofern.
Hast du, du hast doch für die China-Chinesen gerät ein eigenes WLAN, ja hab ich. Wie bekomme
ich das günstig hin, würde da, ja, also Mikrotik kann mehr oder weniger alles was
man braucht, die haben WLAN Support, du kannst mehrere SSIDs haben, das ist kein Ding, wobei
ich sagen muss, die haben mich nicht so überzeugt, die Mikrotik Access Points, ich hab mir das
aktuelle Lineup aber nicht angeguckt, ich bin riesen Fan was Mikrotik Router und Switcher
angeht, gerade im Heimbereich und wenn es preisleistungsmäßig gut sein soll, man kann
sich sowas ohne Probleme auch ins Rechenzentrum hängen, ja, fand ich witzig, könnt ihr euch
auch dran erinnern, es war mal irgendeiner im Stream, da hab ich gesagt, ja, im Zweifelsfall
kannst du dir so ein Mikrotik auch ins Rechenzentrum hängen, da hat der Typ dann hier, es können
auch die Kommentare von YouTube gewesen sein, ich weiß es nicht mehr, wo so ein Besserwisser
wieder am Start war, so nach dem Motto, ha lol Max, sowas hängt man sich doch nicht in
ein Rechenzentrum, in ein Rechenzentrum da kommen Cisco Geräte hin oder DLG, aber Mikrotik,
das kommt nicht ins Rechenzentrum, als weiß der das, ja, als kennt er jedes Rechenzentrum
und auch ein paar billige, die auf ein letztes Loch pfeifen und aufs Geld achten müssen und
weiß das, ja, mit Sicherheit, mit Sicherheit gibt es mehr als genug Serverräume und Rechenzentren,
wo auch, wir reden jetzt ja hier nicht von einem DC Style Riesenrechenzentrum unterirdisch,
es wird genug Rechenzentren geben, wo Mikrotik Geräte rumhängen, es wird genauso gut auch
die ein oder anderen Racks geben, wo tatsächlich Ubiquiti Dinger drinnen hängen, wobei ich
das wirklich nicht ins Rechenzentrum hängen würde, aber was anderes, davon auszugehen,
dass die Leute nur die super krass hochpreisigen Netzwerkgeräte da reinhauen, ist bescheuert,
weil das kostet einfach ein Schweine Geld, guckt euch mal Preise von aktuellen Cisco
Switches an, du kriegst beim Mikrotik einen richtig guten Switch oder einen richtig guten
Router für irgendwas um 1000 Euro, also richtig fetten, bei Cisco bezahlst du dann 35.000
Euro, also der Grab ist mega teuer, deswegen, das hat schon seine Daseinsberechtigung, wenn
ich das Geld hätte, dann sieht das anders aus, aber viele müssen halt tatsächlich ein
bisschen drauf gucken, was sie ausgeben, deswegen so besser wisseregen mich dann auch immer
auf, so als wüssten sie das irgendwie, wie das auf der ganzen Welt so zu sein hat, ja.
Guckt dir mal die Elon Musk Stream hier auf Twitch an, was Elon Musk hat streamt auf Twitch,
das ist doch Scam, oder? Das ist das, was beim M-Core auf dem Channel gelaufen ist,
wo er sein Channel gehackt wurde, diese Scams, ach Deepfakes, ernsthaft? Geil. Ihr hattet
mit dem Mikrotik immer LZ und es war Shit, ja, das ist natürlich nicht gut. Ok, SwitchOS
ist auch Pain in the Ass, ja, mit SwitchOS bin ich auch noch nicht warm geworden, aber
da sieht man es, es gibt ja offensichtlich Rechenzentren, wo Mikrotik steht, zum Beispiel
in eurem, zumindest mal kurzzeitig. Ja, ich
kenne sogar eins, ich kenne sogar zwei, wo eine Fritzbox ist. Das eine ist bei mir auf
der Arbeit, da gibt es nämlich einen kleinen Technikraum mit zwei Racks drinnen, das könnte
man quasi so grob als Rechenzentrum klassifizieren, da stehen zwei Racks drin und neben, auf dem
Schrank neben den Racks, liegt eine Fritzbox. Und wisst ihr wofür die Fritzbox da ist,
das ist gar nicht so dumm, wie es auf den ersten Blick erscheinen mag, dass da eine
Fritzbox da liegt, tatsächlich, ja, ja, ja, ja, da ist ein Notfalltelefon dran, das ist
tatsächlich richtig, habt ihr gut geraten. Aber hauptsächlich ist es dafür da, da ist
nämlich ein extra Internetanschluss hingelegt worden. Sollte mal bei uns wirklich irgendwie
die super krasse Hacker-Scheiße am Start sein oder totaler Netzwerkzusammenbruch oder was
auch immer, in dem Raum gibt es Strom, gut Strom gibt es im EZ auch, aber da gibt es
nochmal extra Strom und es gibt einen DSL-Anschluss mit der Fritzbox, unabhängig von komplett
dem restlichen Netzwerk im Haus. Der Raum ist übrigens abgeschlossen, nur mal so, also
es ist nicht so, dass da irgendjemand reingehen kann und sagen, im Moment, die Jungs, ich
stöpsel mich mal kurz an die Fritzbox an. Also, ist gar nicht so doof, ist gar nicht
so doof, dass es das gibt. Und den zweiten Raum, den ich kenne, war beim ehemaligen Arbeitgeber
im, das war nicht wirklich ein Rechensendung, es war auch so ein Abstellraum, da hing auch
eine Fritzbox. Es hat seinen Sinn, kann durchaus seinen Sinn haben, dass da eine Fritzbox baumelt.
Das ist Pfeilfeld, ja. Hattet ihr noch eine Frage zu deinem Video, Leute, ich muss langsamer,
ich muss langsamer, entspannter und ruhiger reden und zu, mein Hals wieder weh. Das muss
ja nicht sein. Wir machen jetzt ASMR-Stream. Ne, machen wir nicht. Also, ich habe auch
eine Frage zu deinem Video von heute. Gibt es solche Probleme eigentlich auch bei macOS
in meinem Bekanntenkreis heißt es immer, dass das System so sicher ist. Also, das Video
von heute, was ich gemacht habe, da ging es ja. Wollen wir uns das Video noch mal zusammen
angucken und ihr könnt dann was fragen und ich sage noch ein paar Sachen zu, weil es
haben sich ein paar neue Erkenntnisse ergeben in der Zwischenzeit. Zumindest es geht in
dem Video darum, also es geht, aber ihr müsst das Video danach, ich reakte jetzt auf meinen
eigenen Content von heute. Das ist quasi so krasses Content-Recycling, das ist 11-Head
schon. Das müssen wir eigentlich auf das, also in dem Video geht es darum, nur mal ganz
kurz, oder wie Semper Video sagen würde, in diesem Video nur ganz kurz, also es geht
um eine neue Sicherheitslücke aus der Kombination Word plus Windows. Und zwar, Word ist insofern
betroffen, dass man, ich mache jetzt mal ganz kurz einen Recap, vielleicht müssen wir es
uns gar nicht angucken, aber um das hier beantworten zu können, muss ich da ein bisschen ausholen.
Also, genau, also es gibt eine Sicherheitslücke in Word, die es erlaubt Templates nachzuholen,
also Teile, so wie das funktioniert ist. Also du kannst in Word Templates nachladen, das
ist auf Deutsch sowas wie Dokumentenvorlage. Nur hat sich irgendein extrem Sixheader bei
Microsoft gedacht, es ist eine gute Idee, dass man diese Dokumentenvorlagen auch übers
Internet nachladen kann. Wozu das gut sein soll, ich habe keine Ahnung. So, und ein,
tja, da reichen sechs Köpfe gar nicht mehr. Ein Sevenhead bei Microsoft hat sich danach
gedacht, es ist noch besser, wenn wir an unsere Templates Embedded HTML mit JavaScript erlauben.
Das heißt, du kriegst jetzt Microsoft Office Word Dokumente, Vorlagen, Word Vorlagen manipuliert
mit Embedded JavaScript und das ist vollkommen okay und Microsoft sagt, das ist ein Feature,
das muss so sein. Wenn du diese Dokumente öffnest, dann lädt Microsoft automatisch
den JavaScript Code und führt ihn aus. Warum es das macht? Weil sie bescheuert sind, keine
Ahnung. So, und dann kann man hiermit, ja, dann kann man mit diesem manipulierten JavaScript,
das ist nur ein Beispiel, es gibt noch mehr. Ja, also so sieht der Payload aus, der HTML
Payload in dieser Word Vorlage und im Endeffekt passiert Folgendes, die tricksen hier ein
bisschen rum mit ganz vielen A's am Anfang, das dient dazu, dass man an der richtigen Speicheradresse
ist, also wozu sind die ganzen A's, das ist, dass man an der richtigen Speicheradresse
ist, dann wird das umgebogen, die Adresse, auf die das JavaScript zeigt oder auf dem das
aktuelle Browser Fenster zeigt, von HTTP quasi auf MS-MSDT und MS-MSDT dahinter steckt
ein lokales Windows Programm, wo man eigentlich irgendwelche Remote Hilfen drüber anbieten
kann oder irgendwas, irgendwas bescheuertes in Windows und zumindest kann man darüber
dann eine PowerShell starten im Kontext von Word, also im Kontext vom aktuellen User und
dann dementsprechend alles auf dem System machen, was man will. So, ich sag, wir können
uns das gleich zusammen noch mal angucken, aber um diese Frage zu beantworten, gibt
es solche Probleme eigentlich auch bei macOS und eurem Bekannten, das heißt, das System
ist unsicher. Also, das sind ja zwei Probleme. Das erste Problem ist, dass Word, warum mache
ich eigentlich immer gerade ihn auf, so, das erste Problem ist, dass Word so beschissen
ist, genau, man muss doch atmen werden, das ist das einzige, was einen ein bisschen beschützt,
also das erste Problem ist, dass Word so was bescheuertes mit Templates macht und das zweite
Problem ist, dass mit MSDST, ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wie es heißt, das sind
zwei Probleme, deswegen ist auch jeder Windows-User betroffen, das stimmt, was ich da geschrieben
hab, sind zwei unterschiedliche Probleme, die aktuell aber in Kombination ausgenutzt
werden. So, und zu dieser Frage, also das erste ist, Mac hat ja auch Microsoft Word,
ich hab aber keine Ahnung, ob das Word oder Office für Mac die gleichen Schwachstellen
hat, das hängt davon ab, ob die ja zu den gleichen, den gleichen Basis haben, wie das
Office für Windows. Zum Beispiel das Office im Browser hat es logischerweise nicht, also
haben die die gleiche Basis und machen die das gleiche mit Templates, ist das erste Problem
auch genauso unter MacOS. Das zweite Problem mit diesen MSD-Dingsbumms, MSDST-Excel, das
gibt es natürlich unter Mac nicht, weil ja das Programm gibt es unter Mac nicht. Potenziell
geht sowas aber auch unter Mac, weil der eigentliche Ablauf ist äußerst simpel, du
lädst irgendwas runter und der nächste Schritt ist, es muss ausgeführt werden, das ist ja
das Schwierige eigentlich. Egal um welche Virus oder wie Sempervideos sagen wir, Schad
wäre, um die es geht, der erste Schritt, du musst es irgendwie auf das Gerät des Opfers
bringen, das ist aber meistens noch das einfachere, du musst es irgendwie dazu bringen, dass es
ausgeführt wird und dass der Schadcode ausgeführt wird, das ist tatsächlich dann wiederum nicht
so einfach, aber vom Ablauf her in dem Fall ist es total simpel und wenn du dir irgendwas
runterladen würdest und das ausführen aus dem Internet, dann hast du im Prinzip exakt
das gleiche unter jedem Betriebssystem und das gibt es unter Linux tatsächlich total
oft, ja es gibt unter Linux ganz viele Installationsanleitungen, die beispielsweise sowas hier als in ihre Installationsanleitung
reinschreiben. Die sagen Installation ist ganz einfach, du musst einfach nur diesen
Befehl ausführen um unsere Software zu installieren. So und dieser Befehl sieht normalerweise folgendermaßen
aus, ja sinngemäß sowas wie curlcacw.omega-poggers.org slash install.sh gpiped nach bash, so am besten
auch sudo bash, das ist genau der gleiche Scheiß, ja du lädst irgendwas aus dem Internet
runter was du nicht kontrolliert hast und lässt es lokal bei dir ausführen, in dem
Fall sogar noch mit Adminrechten, das ist genau der gleiche Müll wenn man nicht guckt
was man sich runter lädt. Also potenziell hast du so ähnlich gelagerte Probleme selbstverständlich
unter jedem Betriebssystem, das heimtückische bei dieser Lücke ist jetzt eben, dass du es
nicht erkennen kannst. Während du bei sowas relativ offensichtlich siehst, ok ich lade
hier irgendwelche random Sachen von denen ich keine Ahnung hab aus dem Internet und
führe sie in einer Rootshell aus, weißt du das ja bei Dokumentenvorlagen nicht. Du lädst
dir eine Word Dokumentenvorlage runter, machst die auf oder startest den Explorer mit der
Vorschau und dann fängst du dir was ein. Und sowas gibt es natürlich auch unter allen
möglichen Betriebssystemen, ich würde aber sagen, dass das potenziell unter Windows
am häufigsten passiert, hauptsächlich aber, weil Windows das Hauptangriffsziel ist. Sicherlich
auch, weil Windows irgendwie ja jahrzehntelange Exploiterfahrungen die Leute haben, aber man
muss sagen Microsoft macht den Angreifern schon in vielen Fällen wirklich das Leben
sehr schwer. Und es ist nicht so, dass es easy wäre und dass Microsoft, es wird da immer
gerne auf Microsoft rumgebashed, dass Microsoft einfach nur doof wäre. Microsoft, ich glaube
das größte Problem was Microsoft hat ist, dass die jahrzehntelange Legacy Code haben
dennoch in Windows schlummert. Und es sind ja oftmals auch Sicherheitslücken in Bereichen
die uralt sind. Letztens gab es beispielsweise eine Sicherheitslücke in der alten Windows
Hilfe, ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie ich die aufmache Leute. Hat jemand einen Plan wie
man die alte Windows Hilfe öffnet? Wie man das noch aufkriegt? Help? Ne nicht die Help
App, die alte Windows Hilfe. Diese chf oder wie der Kram heißt, files oder ne nicht chf,
ist immer noch drinne. Ne das ist nicht Chrono Trigger Musik, das ist ziemlich sicher Mario
Galaxy. Nein ich mein die, die, wie heißen denn diese alten Windows Hilfe, wir machen
einfach 7zip auf, die haben glaube ich noch sowas. About, ne wo ist Help, Contents, das
Ding meine ich hier. Da gab es nämlich letztens auch in 7zip eine Sicherheitslücke was das
angeht. Ja. So. Ich mein den Kram hier. Da gab es letztens auch eine Sicherheitslücke
und Microsoft schleppt halt jahrzehntelange Legacy Scheiß mit sich rum. Und haben noch
solche Dinger drinne. Ich weiß noch da hab ich mal die Frau in der Bücherei von uns
geschockt früher. Also ich bin ab und zu mal früher in die Bücherei gegangen und da
gab es auch einen Rechner, da konntest du dann irgendwie ne halbe Stunde umsonst benutzen
und sonst musst du bezahlen oder komische Regeln. Zumindest konntest du damals, dieser
Rechner hatte irgendwie so ein komisches Windows mit so nem Kiosk, Kiosk Mode. Das war aber
damals noch frag mich nicht. Windows ist ewig her. Ich weiß nicht ob es noch 98 war oder
schon 2000. Ist aber auch egal. Man konnte aus diesem, aus dieser Kiosk Box total easy
ausbrechen. Das hab ich random rausgefunden an dem, an diesem Rechner in der Bücherei
und zwar, du musstest Word aufmachen, lustigerweise auch Word, ja. Du musstest Word aufmachen
und dann musstest du in Word eine Verknüpfung einfügen und da geht ja so ein Dialogfenster
auf, so wählen sie jetzt das aus, welche Verknüpfung möchten sie dann ausführen
und da konntest du einfach CMD auswählen. Muss ich ja vorstellen. Da konntest du CMD
Verknüpfung in Word machen und dann klicken. Oder hast du nen Shell gehabt. Geiler Kiosk
Modus, oder? Voll geiles Ding ab. Zumindest hab ich das der Frau versucht von der Bücherei
zu zeigen und die hat es halt überhaupt nicht gecheckt. Und die hat sich dann irgendwann
aufgeschrieben, meint, ja das muss sie mal mit ihrem Computerleut besprechen. Die war
auch grade nicht verwirrt danach. Kann ich auch verstehen. Die haben ja da keine Ahnung
von. Wie läufts mit Arch? Naja ich verwende ja im Prinzip schon Arch seit Jahren. Mit
dem neuen hab ich jetzt nicht weitergemacht. Muss ich auch noch machen, das waren so viele
Sachen, die man noch machen muss. Wurz gefixt, nee. Glaube nicht. Ich kann mich jetzt nicht
dran erinnern, dass ich es irgendwann mal ausprobiert habe und es ging nicht, aber ich hab das danach
auch nicht wirklich oft ausprobiert. Du hattest auch gleich Admin, ja das ist halt Fail. Was
für ne Mode? MonkaS als Totenkopf, warum nicht? So also ok, weil ihr seid Leute, wir gucken
jetzt das Video von mir an und ich sag euch noch ein paar Takte zu. Ist es nicht schlecht
für deinen YouTube-Kanal, dass du aus dem Homeoffice arbeitest? Ich mein die ganzen
Storys, die du schon erzählt hast, wären so. Ach nö, ich hab doch auch genug Sachen
erzählt, die nur nicht so lange her sind. Ja das Video kenn ich, das hab ich auch geguckt.
Mal eine sehr oberflächliche Frage. Kann man ein, also ich hab nie Informatik studiert,
ja, muss ich dazu sagen. Nochmal so, auch wenn das Informatiker TV ist, ich hab nie Informatik
studiert. Kann man ein Informatiker als mathematisch durch die begabte Person bewältigen? Du hast
ja wie ich weiß Informatik, achja sagst du ja auch. Ja, also ich kann dir nur das sagen,
was ich von Leuten vernommen habe, die Informatik studiert haben, beziehungsweise teilweise
auch von Leuten, die Mathe studiert haben. Ja, du musst aber bereit sein, nicht damit
auseinander zu setzen. Also du musst das nicht irgendwie, wie soll ich sagen, so instinktiv
gottgegeben alles wissen, du musst dich halt damit auseinandersetzen und das, was man in
der Schule an Mathe gelernt hat, hat damit nicht wirklich großartig was zu tun. Da geht's
eher darum, dass du Sachen beweisen kannst, ja, von Algorithmenlaufzeit, ja, bis was weiß
ich, wie Hash-Algorithmen funktionieren und solche Dinger. Das ist teilweise schon etwas
härtere Kost und dementsprechend musst du dich anstrengen. Und also Mathe ist das,
was den meisten Leuten im Informatikstudio mit Abstand am schwersten fällt, von dem,
was ich so höre. Ja, genau, so würde ich das auch sehen. Man muss sich da einfach,
wenn es dir halt aber komplett zuwider ist und du quasi kotzen musst, sobald es dahin
geht, dann wird das nichts. Ja, also wenn du sagst, hier, ich kann mir das einfach nicht
geben, dann wirst du es wahrscheinlich nicht schaffen, weil da kommst du nicht drumherum.
Sowas hattet ihr in Mathe nie? Moment, ihr hattet in Mathe im Informatikstudio nie Algorithmenlaufzeit
abschätzen? Bestimmt. Was ist das für ein Informatikstudium? What the fuck? Sowas ist
da doch eigentlich Standard. Also das weiß ich nicht, was, wahrscheinlich Wirtschaftsinformatik
oder sowas. Nee, keine Ahnung. Es war bei euch nicht Teil von Mathe, sondern vom Algorithmus-Konkurs.
Ja Leute, jetzt sind sie mal wieder päpstlicher als der Papst, Alter, im Chat. Ist doch egal,
das muss er auch durch. Ja, den hab ich auch schon gesehen. Den Proof of Concept für Folina.
Sprich man das eigentlich aus? Das müssen wir uns jetzt mal. Das ist ja was in Italien.
Jetzt hören wir mal, wer Folina ausspricht. Nein, so spricht das kein Italiener aus, definitiv
nicht. Folina. Folina. Folina. Das hört sich deutlich Italienischer an. Folina heißt
das. Sonst Chat durch. Das probier ich jetzt nicht aus. Ist eine äußerst, ich muss sagen,
eine äußerst unglückliche Benahmung dieses Programms. Schon Amazon Stonks Aktie angeschaut?
Oh, muss ich mal gucken. Gab's da heute Big Stonks? Also ich hab tatsächlich relativ
viel gut Stonks gemacht. Die letzte Woche waren 850 Euro mehr oder so. Moment, mal kurz
meine Amazon Stonks checken. Na ja. Oh, nee nicht? Na ja, Pog. Das ist ja geil. Das hab
ich mir noch gar nicht angeguckt. Ich hab Amazon gekauft bei um die 2000 und jetzt ist
es 2317. Also one week 377 Euro. Na dann. Massive Stonks. Jetzt verkaufe ich die einfach
wieder. Da hab ich mir ein bisschen Kohle ausgemacht. Ja, also genau. Wenn schon Leute, dann macht
so wie ich mit meinen Stonks, weil ich hab trotzdem, dass es die letzte Woche ziemlich
gut war, hab ich in diesem Jahr minus 1000, nee stimmt nicht, minus 908 Euro und 67 Cent
gemacht. Also beste, beste Stonks Beratung hier bei mir. Weil wenn ihr Geld verlieren
wollt, dann macht es so wie ich. Worüber kaufst du? Ich hab Scalable als App. Kann ich gar
nicht mehr sagen warum. Ich glaub, das würde öfters auf YouTube und öfters auf Reddit
empfohlen. Eine Milliarde Bits? Dankeschön. Jetzt ist alles weg. Jetzt bin ich wieder
reich. Alle Stonks Verluste ausgeglichen durch Twitch Bits. Polina könnten ohne Probleme
irgendwelche Nudeln sein in irgendwie geschwungener Form oder so. Es gibt ja 30 Milliarden Nudelsorten.
Wolle, danke für den Sub. Übrigens danke für alle, die gestubbt haben, die ich übersehen
hab. Schau mal kurz. Wolle hat gesagt, Battle Day Z, Dates. Danke schön für den Sub.
DasSteinAtler5 hat Subscribed. Danke schön. KioKun wieder am Start. Oder Samuel, ja euch
hab ich schon gesehen. Gut, nice. So, ja gut Leute, dann gucken wir jetzt mal schnell
mein Video und ich sag noch was zu, weil es haben sich in ein paar Kleinigkeiten jetzt
noch ergeben. Achtung. Eigenen Content Recycle im Stream am gleichen Tag. Das ist Pog, so
muss man das machen. Scale Capital, ja. Muss man da was beachten? Naja. Du brauchst einen
gültigen Personalausweis, weil du Post-Ident machen musstest und ich hatte keinen zu dem
Zeitpunkt. Muss mir vorübergehenden Personalausweis holen. Leute, das war auch, hab ich euch das
erzählt mit dem Perso, was es für ein Act war? Alter, ich wollte nach Hanau mir einen
Personalausweis holen, weil ich Post-Ident machen muss und die hatten irgendwie 6 Wochen
keinen Termin. Und dann hab ich mir gedacht, ok, guckst du mal beim Bundesinnenministerium
nach auf der Webseite, was die sagen, was man in besonders dringenden Fällen machen
soll. Und da steht, in besonders dringenden Fällen kann jedes beliebige, ja, Niederlassungsbürger
Amtsstelle dir einen temporären Personalausweis ausstellen. Jede. Das steht auf der Webseite
vom Bundesinnenministerium. Also hab ich in der Nachbarschaft rumgeguckt, also in Nachbargemeinden
und so rumgeguckt und da hab ich einen Stadtteil gefunden von Offenbach, also quasi bei Haftbefehl
um die Ecke und hab da angerufen und hab gesagt, wie sieht es denn bei euch aus, ich
bräuchte einen neuen Personalausweis, ganz dringend, weil Post-Ident und so und das ist
eilig und ich muss da dran. Und kleines Problem ist aber, der Tipp könnte tatsächlich aus,
nee, weiß ich nicht, ob dieser Tipp aus dem Chat gekommen ist, aber der Chat hat auf jeden
Fall Fivehead-Ideen gehabt und da hab ich gesagt, das Problem ist nur, ich komm nicht
aus ihrer Gemeinde, ich komm aus Hanau und da hat die dann gleich zu mir gesagt, nee,
nee, das geht nicht und dann hab ich gesagt, Fivehead-Modus aktiviert und dann hab ich
gesagt, doch, das geht in dringenden Fällen, das steht nämlich sogar auf der Seite vom
Bundesinnenministerium und dann hat die gesagt, ach ja, ah ja, wenn das da steht, dann geht
das. Ja, die hatte bloß keinen Bock, die wollte bloß nicht, die hatte bloß keinen Bock. Aber
als ich ihr das dann quasi zitiert habe von, dann hat das funktioniert und die war auch
wirklich sehr nett und sehr schnell. Tag später konnte ich den Gramm holen. Tja, der
gilt aber nur drei Monate. Das heißt, ich müsste jetzt so langsam aber sicher mal wirklich
nach Hanau einen Termin machen. Ja, das hab ich mal sogar auf Twitter gepostet, die Heckler
und Kochakte ging ja auch übelst ab, die ganzen Rüstungsunternehmen, die haben halt
richtig am Anfang richtig massive Stonks gemacht. Also ganz ehrlich, ich nehm dir das
nicht böse, man muss gucken, wo man bleibt. Man kann sich nicht darauf verlassen, dass
irgendjemand, weder den man wählt noch irgendjemand anderes, was in seinem eigenen Interesse macht,
nachdem jeder gucken muss, woran er bleibt, warum nicht? Es ist ja nicht so, als würdest
du damit irgendwie Kinder erschießen oder so. Zumindest nicht du persönlich. Was da
mit den Sachen passiert, sei mal dahingestellt. Aha, das macht ihr da. Tja, gut, damit hab
ich zum Glück nichts am Hut. Gab es heute schon überfüllte Züge, ich musste heute
zum Glück nicht fahren. Ich bin zuletzt gefahren am Dienstag und da war außer 10 Minuten Verspätung
mittags, das ist aber eigentlich schon, ja was heißt, da twitter ich schon gar nicht
mehr drüber, wenn es einfach nur 10, 15 Minuten Verspätung sind, ohne was, war es relativ
problemlos, ja. Bin aber mal gespannt, wie das wird nächste Woche. Na gut, okay, also
gucken wir uns mal mein Video an, ich erzähle euch ein paar neue Sachen zu. Hallo Leute,
hier ist der Max und haltet euch fest. Inception, Inception. Heute wird's wild. Übrigens, wisst
ihr, wie ich das Video zuerst nennen wollte? Leute, ich hatte richtige Probleme, dieses
Video hochzuladen. Das muss ich jetzt hier an der Stelle einfach nochmal kurz erzählen.
Und zwar, ich hatte mega Probleme, das Video hochzuladen. Ursprünglicher Titel dieses
Videos war, wilde Sicherheitslücke in Word und Windows. Jeder ist betroffen und dieser
Titel ging einfach nicht. Immer wurde das Video geplockt, also geplockt, halt entmonitarisiert.
So, und dann habe ich verschiedene Variationen ausprobiert mit dem Titel und das war der
einzige Titel, den YouTube gefressen hat. So, also ohne Microsoft im Titel. Danach habe
ich unten drunter in das Kommentarfeld versucht, die Links einzufügen zu diesen Blogartikeln,
worüber ich rede im Video, Video wieder entmonitarisiert. So, danach habe ich einfach nur meine Social
Media Links eingefügt, Video entmonitarisiert. So, und dann musste ich exakt diesen Text
nehmen, ich habe das Video 5-6 mal hochgeladen insgesamt. Und dann musste ich genau diesen
Text nehmen und ich durfte nicht schreiben, große Sicherheitslücke in Word und Windows,
weil Word anscheinend ein super triggendes Wort ist, sondern ich musste aus Word Microsoft
Word machen und dann wurde es monetarisiert. Warum? Man hat keine Ahnung. YouTube sagt
einem das ja auch nicht, warum was entmonitarisiert wird. YouTube sagt einfach nur BAM, not suitable
für irgendwie Advertisement, limited ads. Keine Ahnung. Nee, ich gehe auch nicht davon
aus, dass die das wissen. Ja, du kannst bei YouTube dann eine Überprüfung beantragen,
die dauert aber höchstwahrscheinlich eine ganze Weile und im Zweifelsfall landest du
dann noch bei irgendeinem unwissenden Kacknoob, der dich fleckt für Hacker-Content. Also
ich habe null Vertrauen in YouTube, was diese Abläufe angeht. Gar nichts, null. So, wir
gucken uns trotzdem jetzt das Video an und ich sage noch ein paar Takte zu. Eine neue
Sicherheitslücke in Word und in Windows. Ich gebe zu, das an sich ist jetzt weder wild
noch sonderlich überraschend, das kommt ja nur öfters mal vor, aber ich verspreche
euch diesmal wird es wirklich wild, denn es sind gleich mehrere Probleme, Word selber,
aber auch Windows eigene Tools. Das geht am Ende so weit, dass jeder der Word nur installiert
hat betroffen sein kann. Ja, was ich hier hätte dazu sagen sollen ist, potenziell
jeder der Word installiert hat, ist von der Word-Problematik betroffen, aber jeder, deswegen
habe ich jetzt auch einen Titel geschrieben, jeder Windows-Benutzer ist von der zweiten
Hälfte dieses Problems betroffen. Als wäre das noch nicht genug, ist das Ganze
auch noch ziemlich einfach auszunutzen und wird auch schon aktiv ausgenutzt. Gibt es
mehrere Beispiele für, also das in der Kombination kommt doch relativ selten vor und übrigens
der Windows-Defender hat auch seine Probleme damit das ganze festzustellen.
Und ja, das ist immer noch so, weil ein paar Leute in den Kommentaren geschrieben haben
ja, der Windows-Defender würde das erkennen, wenn man sich die Paid-Lizenz von Microsoft
dafür kauft. Naja, das erste ist, keiner hat diese Paid-Windows-Defender-Lizenz, also
der Windows-Defender macht bei 99,9% der Windows-Benutzer nichts. Ist das eigentlich der Windows-11-Marketing-Trailer?
Nee, der Windows-11-Trailer, den habe ich nachher aber auch noch drin. Und, was wollte
ich jetzt sagen, ich darf nicht Chat lesen auf dem zweiten Bildschirm, das lenkt mich
teilweise so ab, dass mein Boomer-Prain das nicht mehr mitmacht. Was habe ich gesagt
gerade Chat, 11 mal auf die Sprünge, Boomer-Alarm, dass der Defender nichts dagegen macht, genau
habe ich gesagt. Ja, und das 99% der Leute, die eben keine Cloud-Sache haben. Das nächste
ist, selbst der Windows-Defender mit irgendwelchen Cloud-AI-Five-Hat-Geschichten dabei, erkennt
das auch nicht richtig. Mittlerweile, wenn man die Ursprungs-Datei hoch lädt, ja, dann
sieht man auch auf Virus-Total, das kann ich euch ja an der Stelle zeigen, das ist der
ursprüngliche Twitter-Post, wo das angekündigt wurde, ja, und wenn man jetzt hier auf Virus-Total
geht, 38 von 62 erkennen diesen Kram mittlerweile zum größten Teil irgendwie als Generic und
hier als Word-Fail, erkennen das Ding als Virus, aber das ist die ursprüngliche Datei,
und wenn man das, dass sie den GitHub-Proof-of-Concept erkennen, wundert mich auch nicht, aber du
kannst halt hier relativ easy variieren, ja, allein schon das Encoding, wenn du das änderst,
sieht das komplett anders aus danach, und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die mittlerweile
schon checken, sind dort irgendwelche Aufrufe drin, MS, MSDT, aber das kannst du ja beliebig
obfoscaden, und ich gehe davon aus, wenn man das geschickt macht, dann wird das kein Virenscanner
wirklich stichhaltig erkennen. Was ist die MP6-Stub-Axe, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich versuche,
ich denke mal irgendwas für Signaturen oder so, ich weiß es nicht. Wobei man sagen muss,
das hier ist ja auch der ursprüngliche russische oder weißrussische Code, die versuchen da
auch Gerafiles zu entpacken drin, vielleicht hat es damit was zu tun, keine Ahnung wofür
das in dem Fall da ist. Wichtig an der Stelle ist übrigens, dass MSDST aufgerufen wird
mit IT-Browse-for-File oder IT-Run, nee IT-Rebrowse-for-File, das ist wichtig, weil ansonsten
sieht man ein Popup, und Popups machen die Leute ja erst mal skeptisch, und wenn man
das angibt, gibt es noch nicht mal ein Popup. Muss ich mal überlegen, was für ein Abfakt
das eigentlich ist, dass du Word-Vorlagen überhaupt mit Embedded JavaScript ausführen kannst,
der dann im Word-Kontext läuft und sich weitere Dinger runter, das ist doch total hängengebliebener
Müll, ja. Also wer sich bei Microsoft denkt, das ist eine gute Idee, verstehe ich nicht.
Äh, wo ist denn, wait a minute, Leute wo ist mein Video hin, da, wer auf Nummer sicher
gegangen ist in der Vergangenheit und seine Makros in Word... Moment, ganz kurz war es
im Chat noch ziemlich ein Problem beim Abspiel von Videos in VMWare Pro, hast du eine Idee
woran das liegt? Ja, weil du in der VM kein Hardware-Video-Decoder hast, also da ist hohe
CPU-Last normal, wenn du versuchst dort 1080p plus Videos abzuspielen, teilweise schon mal
720p Videos, je nachdem wie stark dein Rechner ist, dann ruckelst, weil du keinen Hardware-Decoder
hast, weil alles komplett von der CPU decodet werden muss. Das habe ich auch, wenn ich in
meine VM gehe und mache jetzt hier mal mein Video auf, ja, nehmen wir mal irgendwas mit
ein bisschen Bewegung drin, ich gehe mal hier mal rein, oh die muss ich mal neu starten,
die ist ziemlich lahm. Nehmen wir mal hier irgendwie das da zum Beispiel, und ich stelle
das Ganze jetzt tatsächlich mal auf 1440p, dann gucken wir mal Hardtop an, da siehst
du Firefox, Moment, ja, wenn ich ihn aufmache noch mehr, da siehst du mal, also es ist ordentlich,
ordentlich, guck mal, also es sind 4 CPU-Kerne jeweils zu einem Viertel ausgelassen, schon
ordentlich, also das ist normal, dass du da hohe CPU-Auslastung hast. Leider, es gibt
keine Möglichkeit den Hardware-Decoder zu verwenden, es sei denn, du benutzt was anderes
und machst dann GPU-Pass-Through, aber da hast du komplett andere Probleme wieder. Nö,
das ist ganz normal, das kann man scheinbar nicht. Achso, ja, dann, dann weiß ich auch
nicht, wenn du es gar nicht sehen kannst. Da braucht man auch normalerweise nichts zusätzlich
installieren, weil das alles im Browser dabei ist. Ne, dann weiß ich es auch nicht, wenn
du es nicht abspielen kannst, keine Ahnung. Ja, guck mal die CPU-Auslastung an, ansonsten
weiß ich es nicht. GPU-Pass-Through geht überhaupt nicht ohne Probleme, also ja, GPU-Pass-Through
geht ohne Probleme, aber das was daraus resultiert, die Probleme gibt es immer noch. Ja, zum
Beispiel, dass du dann erst einmal die Grafikkarte nicht im Hausbetriebssystem hast, wenn du
GPU-Pass-Through gemacht hast. Das heißt, wie guckst du dir dann dein Hausbetriebssystem
an? Ich weiß, du kannst dann wieder sowas wie Looking Class machen und dann doch noch
ein bisschen weniger Delay haben, du kannst mit Virtual GL rum, jaja, aber das sind im
Prinzip alles was ich meine, du hast dann andere Probleme. Dann musst du gucken wie
du deine Maus Pass-Throughs, also du kannst zwei GPUs kannst du auch machen, ja klar,
vielleicht machst du komplett USB-Root-Dings Pass-Through, also du hast dann andere Probleme,
die du lösen musst, dass das funktioniert. Ich weiß, dass du USB-Geräte Pass-Through-kannst,
also sobald du USB-Geräte Pass-Throughs, kannst du sie nicht mehr auf dem Host verwenden,
das heißt du brauchst dann theoretisch zwei Mäuse und zwei Monitore und vielleicht, vielleicht
sogar zwei GPUs, was du natürlich am Ende nicht wirklich brauchst, sondern du kannst
dann sowas wie mit Looking Class tricksen, dass du sagst, ok, ich nehme minimalen Lack
im Kauf, dass ich das dann aber alles über den Host machen kann, du hast dann einfach
andere Probleme und das ist das was ich meine, das ist cool, dass das geht, du hast dann
einfach andere Probleme, die du lösen musst. Es gibt für fast alles irgendwelche Lösungen,
mal mehr, mal weniger gefrickelt. So, jetzt gucken wir jetzt aber endlich mal, jetzt wird
das ja heute gar nichts mehr. Ein falsches, falsches Video. Komplett ausgeschaltet hat,
klingt alles nix, schützt euch nicht davor. Ausnutzen lässt sich das Ganze aktuell wohl
in einer breiten Anzahl an Office-Versionen von Office 2013 bis 2016, 2019, übrigens
für alle die es immer noch nicht mitbekommen haben, das heißt eigentlich gar nicht mehr
Office 365, sondern mittlerweile heißt es Windows 365, falls Sie es nicht schon wieder
umbenannt haben. Ernsthaft? Ne, oder? Doch. Microsoft ist sich selber nicht so ganz einig
wie der Campbell heißt. Ach du Scheiße, Microsoft und Benahmung. Ja, aber Office 365 heißt eigentlich
Windows 365 mittlerweile. Der Name ist lächerlich, ich meine, warum heißt das Office?
Man weiß auch nicht, heißt es Microsoft 365, heißt es Windows 365, Microsoft und Benahmung.
Dass es das überhaupt gibt, dann Office Pro Plus und natürlich auch und das ist wahrscheinlich
das Wichtigste, Office 365 und das ist jetzt eine Anmerkung von mir, was ich jetzt dazu
sage, das steht nicht in den offiziellen Analysedokumenten drin, wer Office 365 nur im Browser benutzt,
der müsste wahrscheinlich safe sein. Es geht darum, wenn ihr das auf eurem Windows Rechner
verwendet. Ja, also was ist los? Übrigens, wo wir gerade dabei sind, ich komme aktuell
leider wenig dazu, so viele Videos rauszuhauen, wie ich gerne möchte. Ja, das ist tatsächlich
leider so, ich würde lieber mehr Videos machen als so wenige, aber dafür muss ich sagen,
eine Sache, die mich wirklich freut, ist, das aktuelle Video kommt auch relativ gut
an und das letzte Video kam wirklich gut an. Also gerade für so ein Thema sind 65.000
Views wirklich nicht übel und auch eine richtig viele Anzahl an Comments. Comments wäre nicht
so ausführlich vom Text her, da würde dann drin stehen Plupfix 1 oder sowas. Und ansonsten
insgesamt muss ich wirklich sagen, Chat, ich kann mich echt nicht beschweren. Ich mache
diesen Krempel auf YouTube jetzt seit 12 Jahren fast, nicht ganz, aber seit 2010 und ich denke,
das können nicht viele Leute von sich behaupten, dass sie 12 Jahre auf YouTube sind und im
aktuellen Jahr, quasi wenn man sich die Videos anguckt, immer noch Views haben, die, ja nicht,
das kann man schlecht vergleichen. Ich meine, ich habe damals Videos rausgehauen, 5 Minuten
am Call of Duty Gameplay gemacht und hatte teilweise 60.000 Views am zweiten Tag. So
ist es nicht, aber die YouTube Welt hat sich geändert. Aber wenn man das mal im Verhältnis
sich anguckt, nach 12 Jahren YouTube bekommen meine Videos immer noch ähnlich viele Aufrufe
wie damals zum Call of Duty Hype und ich denke, das können wirklich nicht viele Leute sagen,
dass sie nach 12 Jahren immer noch die Leute auf YouTube erreichen können und das mit
teilweise komplett anderem Zeug als damals. Da bin ich wirklich froh drum, dass das so
gut geklappt hat oder dass das so gut funktioniert. Und was mich auch wieder daran bestätigt,
dass ich eine wirklich besondere Zuschauergruppe habe, also damit seid jetzt natürlich auch
indirekt, ist der Chat gemeint und zwar, das kannst du aber auch erst haben, wenn du eine
Weile auf YouTube dabei bist und zwar die Leute, die mich damals geguckt haben und ich
weiß das aus dem Chat, weil da sind öfters mal welche, die genau das schreiben. Die Leute
waren damals zwölf, dreizehn, vierzehn, fünfzehnjährige Call of Duty Kinder. Jetzt
ohne das abwertend zu meinen, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine, da sind die Leute, die damals
in die Kommentare gegangen sind und haben dann reingeschrieben, ah Max, du kack Spaß,
du spielst Xbox, fuck Vixbox, Playstation 3 for life. Ja, okay, so Leute waren das und
die sind heute noch da, zwar natürlich nicht alle, aber zum Gehirn, das war mir klar,
also du bist der Erste, der mich das zugetraut hätte, sowas. Zumindest, die Leute sind heute
immer noch da, aber das Geile ist, die Leute sind mit mir quasi gewachsen oder mit mir
älter geworden, also sprich, ich war damals paarundzwanzig, jetzt bin ich siebenunddreißig
und die anderen Leute, die sind heute zwischen 22 und 27. Das ist halt krass, oder? Das haben
nicht viele auf YouTube, wirklich nicht. Nicht nur ihr seid alt geworden, ich auch. Geht
zwischen 21 und 27 und viele tatsächlich mittlerweile auch in der IT. Ich mein, was mich ja wirklich
freut ist, ich muss sagen, ich hab die Videos damals nicht mit dem Hinblick darauf gemacht,
weil ich mir dachte, es interessiert eh keinen, aber anscheinend hat es doch jemand interessiert.
Ich hab mir damals schon viele Videos gemacht über Fachinformatiker-Ausbildung, über Beruf
an sich und sowas. Wir haben jetzt schon viele Leute hier im Twitch-Chat gesagt, als auch
in den YouTube-Kommentaren gesagt, dass sie nur deswegen, weil ich sie da mal drauf gebracht
hab, letztendlich das dann auch sich angeguckt haben und deswegen auch machen. Das ist halt
wirklich was, da gibt es wirklich nicht viele, die das sagen können, weil das ist ja, das
ist jetzt nicht irgendeinen Schwachsinnseinfluss auf die Leute, sondern es ist tatsächlich,
man hat da tatsächlich, man hat irgendwie auch noch was Gutes bewirkt, ja. Das hätte
ich damals nicht gedacht. Sieht man eigentlich so, ich seh das manchmal, weil ich noch E-Mail-Benachrichtigungen
von damals habe auf Google-Mail. Du selbst, weiß ich nicht, doch man selbst kann das bestimmt
auch irgendwie sehen. Nö, hab ich nicht. So, aber jetzt müssen wir das endlich. Du hast
die Zusage für die, äh, ich erinnere mich, du hast letztens was geschrieben im Chat. Jaja.
Äh, Moment, Leute, ich mach jetzt mal Pfeiffer-Time, ich kann doch nachgucken, was die Leute zuletzt
im Chat geschrieben haben. Da muss ich mich gar nicht dran erinnern. Massive. Also, deine
letzte Chat-Nachricht für heute, Tommy, war Betge. Beste Chat-Nachricht überhaupt. Betge
ist in 13 Minuten auch angesagt. Passt. Also, eine zeitlose Chat-Nachricht, Betge. Ach ja,
jetzt weiß ich's wieder. Du hast geschrieben mit dem Third-Level-Support. Jaja, okay, jetzt
erinnere ich mich wieder. Und dass du dich beworben hast. Ja, freut mich, dass das geklappt
hat. Jetzt hoffen wir, dass es auch gut läuft. Gläserne Viewer. Jaja, hier ist nichts. Leute,
nicht dass ihr denkt, im Zweifelsfall kann ich nachgucken. Und noch schlimmer, wisst
ihr was noch schlimmer ist? Muss mir der Serious Max mal sagen, ob das stimmt. Die Mods können
das auch sehen. Also, wenn irgendjemand sagt, warum wurde ich gebannt mit meinem anderen
Account? Ich hab doch nie was Schlimmes gesagt. Da guckt einfach irgendein Mod rein. Und höchstwahrscheinlich
habt ihr irgendwas Schlimmes gesagt. Oder irgendwas. Ich hab ja teilweise auch schon
Leute gebannt, weil sie mich einfach so sehr abgefuckt haben. Ich banne meist... Ich temp-banne
eigentlich nur Leute. Ich hab ganz selten wirklich Leute richtig gebannt. Also meistens
temp-banne ich nur Leute. Und ich gebe zu, ich hab auch schon Leute temp-bannt... Ach
ja, Chainloids, wo du da bist, ich muss mal kurz auf deine Nachrichten klicken. Du hast
insgesamt schon... Alter! Der Chainloy ist der Ober-Spammer, man! Wie viel der schon
gepostet hat. Das ist so viel, das passt da gar nicht rein. Ähm, tja. Ja, ich temp-banne
in der Regel eigentlich nur Leute. Und ich gebe zu, ich hab auch schon Leute echt mal
im Affekt temp-bannt. Und eine Sache, was mich immer hart triggert, wenn ich irgendwas
nicht hinbekomme, sei es wenn mir irgendwas programmieren oder irgendwas konfiguriert
wird oder irgendwas nicht will oder beim Löten was nicht klappt. Keine Ahnung. Wenn was ist
und die Leute fangen so ultra krass an zu backseaten. So nach dem Motto, ja, probier
mal das aus, ja, guck dir mal das, hast du den Link schon gesehen? Und in der Regel,
ist es so, meistens kenn ich das schon, ja. Die Leute kommen dann ins Stream rein, wissen
nicht was die letzte Stunde war und schreiben dann so nach dem Motto, ja, mach doch mal
das, hast du das schon ausprobiert, jetzt mach doch mal endlich hier. Da flippe ich
immer aus bei, da hab ich auch schon Leute temp-bannt, weil es mir auf den Keks gegangen
ist. Also das ist, ähm, warst du früher Admin auf dem Teamspeak? Nee. Ja, könnte man
so sagen. Die Leute haben aber auch teilweise schon richtig krass genervt, also. Ich war
weder Teamspeak-Mod noch Reddit-Mod. Ich hab aber gehört, ganz ehrlich, dass, äh, wenn
man mal so eine Mod-Tierlist machen würde, hab ich gehört, dass Discord-Mods wohl die
schlimmsten sein sollen. Also nicht Discord-Mods bei mir und auch nicht Discord-Mods von meinen
Mods, die einfach jetzt zufälligerweise auch Mods im Discord sind. Ähm, aber so, wenn
man so ein Mod-Tier-Ranking machen würde, wären wahrscheinlich Discord-Mods die schlimmsten.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich dicht gefolgt von Reddit-Mods, ja. Reddit-Mods sind auch
so. 4chan-Mods, da krieg ich wenig moderiertes mit. Ich bin aber auch schon lange kein regelmäßiger
4chan-Leser mehr. Und auch kein 8chan-Leser und was es nicht alles gibt. Das hab ich vor
langer Zeit, also bestimmt seit 2012, 2013, ja, lese ich das nicht mehr aktiv. Ja gut,
die haben ja auch einiges zu tun. Also als Zoomer müsstest du wissen, was 4chan ist.
Bestimmt, es sind auch Leute auf Program und sowas noch. Also gerade Zoomer müssten doch
eigentlich wissen, was 4chan ist, oder? Und wenn du Anime-Schauender-Zoomer bist, dann
hast du recht. So, jetzt mal endlich mal fertig. Guck mal, es wird nichts mehr hier, Leute,
heute. Also, jetzt widmen wir uns mal der aktuellen Office-Sicherheitslücke, weil es gibt tatsächlich
noch ein paar Sachen, die ich dazu sagen wollte. Ihr könnt mich übrigens abonnieren, wenn
euch der Content gefällt. Wer auch nicht hat, ne? Also, by the way, Sub-Abo-Falle. Wir haben
vor allem auch im YouTube-Algorithmus, und das ist natürlich heutzutage unglaublich
wichtig. Und da solche Themen immer komplexer sind, als es auf den ersten Blick erscheint
oder auf den ersten Blick wirkt, hab ich euch auch unten nochmal die ganzen Seiten verlinkt,
auf denen ich... Ja, das hab ich versucht, aber YouTube hat
mich nicht gelassen. Leider sind Word-Dokumente auch heutzutage immer
noch eine beliebte Form des Datenaustauschs. Ich frag mich gerade an der Stelle, ob sie
bei uns auf der Arbeit den Kram per Gruppenrichtlinie deaktiviert haben oder so. Ansonsten wird's
wahrscheinlich am Morgen lustig. Zum Glück hab ich hier wenigstens nichts zu tun.
Es stoms auch privat. Die Leute schicken sich gerne Doc-Files rum, obwohl es viel bessere
Alternativen gibt. Ja, einfach online auf ne Seite oder im Zweifelsfall ein PDF gemacht.
Aber nein, die Leute schicken sich gerne Doc-Files rum. Aber diesmal betrifft es nicht nur Doc-Files.
Gute Frage. Face... Face? Oh, ich kann dich nicht aussprechen. Ich kann dich nicht aussprechen.
Ich kann dich nicht aussprechen. Phasero... Son... Keine Ahnung. Oder soll man das überhaupt
als A aussprechen? Phar... Pharazon? Ja, aber um auf deine Frage einzugehen. Max, hatte
deine Firma schon mal Hacker-Man-Angriffe, wo was passiert ist? Ja, hatten wir schon.
Und zwar die dümmsten der dummen Angriffe. Und zwar, irgendjemand hat es geschafft, einem
ungesicherten Windows-Server... Ne, muss ich anders anfangen. Einen Windows-SFTP-Server
muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, dass es sowas überhaupt gibt. Einen Windows-SFTP-Server
ungesichert mit alter Windows-Version ins Internet zu hängen. So. Und das haben irgendwelche
Hacker-Mans rausbekommen. Und daraufhin... Ja, ging es dann weiter. Im Detail erzähle
ich es jetzt nicht. Oh no no, ja. Das war auch so was ganz Spezielles. So, weiter. Kommen
wir aber am Schluss vom Video zu. Ich muss erst ein bisschen ausholen, um was es eigentlich
geht. Also, wir gucken uns jetzt mal grob an, um was geht es bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Und, ja, dann natürlich auch, was kann man denn... Ja, Major Lazer, da bist du schon lange
dabei. Ja, das habe ich euch ja gerade schon gezeigt. Ja, das habe ich euch ja gerade schon
gezeigt. Denke ich mal, nennt ein Word-Dokument entdeckt, das von einer IP-Ausweis Russland
oder Belarus, sollten wir glaube ich heutzutage eher sagen, raufgeladen wurde. Was haben
die bei Virus... Was ist da? Was hat es eigentlich... Ich meine, es kann doch nicht sein, dass
die gesamte RKM-Geschichte in letzter Zeit entweder China-Chinesen oder Russen sind.
Wo ist denn der Rest? Die gibt es doch auch noch. Total entdeckt und das ist jetzt ja,
sag mal, so irgendwelche Word-Dokumente mit fragwürdigem Inhalt, ja, da aus Russland
und der Ecke. Das ist jetzt ja erstmal nichts Besonderes. Die machen alle VPN nach Russland
mit NordVPN wahrscheinlich, ja. Wobei, ohne Scheiß, das kann wirklich sein, ne? Das ist
gar nicht mal so unwahrscheinlich, dass die meisten... Also, was ich letztens gelesen
habe, ist, dass für die richtig krassen Hacker-Mans nun VPN in den Iran wohl angesagt ist. Ich
wusste gar nicht, dass der Iran VPN-Anbieter hat, aber anscheinend muss das aktuell angesagt
sein, dass man als Hacker über zig Proxies geht und über iranische VPNs. Warum Iran?
Ich kann es mir nur so erklären, dass dort halt es keiner mit, tja, Nachvollziehbarkeit
sonderlich ernst nimmt und da auch keine Gesetze für gibt. Diesmal war es tatsächlich
was Spannendes, denn es ging um einen neuen Zero-Day-Exploit für Word. Ja, der ist heute
nicht wirklich mehr Zero-Day, weil eigentlich ist die Sicherheitslücke schon seit 5 Tagen
bekannt. Das hört sich natürlich an mit einem manipulierten Word-Dokument. Aber es hört
sich besser an. Das sagt an sich nichts Besonderes. Tausende Sicherheitslücken fangen mit einem
manipulierten Word-Dokument an. Leider auch 2022 noch. So, und in diesem Fall nutzt das
Word-Dokument Templates. Ich frage mich gerade, wie Templates auf Deutsch heißt, wahrscheinlich
sowas wie... Ja, weiß das jemand? Heißt das Dokumentenvorlage oder so in Word auf Deutsch?
Templates? Bestimmt Dokumentenvorlage, ja. Microsoft Word Dokumentenvorlagen oder sowas.
Ich hab geraten im Video. Ja, wahrscheinlich Dokumentenvorlage wird das wahrscheinlich
heißen. So was da. Aber die verwenden nicht... Wobei es um die ja gar nicht geht. Nein, die
verwenden Remote Templates. Das heißt... Ich fände es immer noch so affig, dass es
überhaupt möglich ist, ne? Remote Templates. Man kann die Dokumentenvorlagen, die müssen
nicht lokal sein, sondern die kann man von irgendwo downloaden. Das passiert normalerweise
nur, wenn das Dokument geöffnet wird. Wie gesagt, normalerweise. Diesmal ist es leider
ein bisschen schlimmer. So. Das klingt alleine ja schon etwas, wie man heutzutage... Da bin
ich sehr stolz drauf, Leute. Dass ich diesen Gag jetzt auch mal machen konnte....sagen
wir denn. Sass. Also sprich, das Word......von irgendwelchen Quellen im Internet sich Templates
runterladen kann und das einfach passiert, nur wenn man das Dokument öffnet. Aber das
ist Absicht und das ist ein Feature. Das soll so sein. Und das ist auch nur der Einstieg
bei dem ganzen Problem, denn es reicht nicht einfach nur, dass man Word Templates... Ob
das mit Signaturen in Office möglich ist, das ist eine gute Frage. Also, keine Ahnung,
habe ich nichts zugelesen. Ich denke nicht, weil in dem Fall ist es ja so, dass das HTML
und der JavaScript da drin von Word intern quasi ausgeführt werden und das wird wahrscheinlich
bei Signaturen nicht passieren. Also, mich würde es wundern, wenn Signaturen mit JavaScript
überhaupt ein Ding wären. Bestimmt ist Zenitized vorher. Wie bricht man das überhaupt so aus?
Also, Escaped. Ich glaube nicht, dass es mit Signaturen funktioniert. Irgendwo sonst wie
im Internet runterladen kann. Nein, nein. Ja, du musst ja... Dark Zone, du musst ja noch
nicht mal anklicken. Das ist ja das Fatale da dran. Das sieht man ja später gleich.
In diesen Templates kann auch HTML-Code eingefügt sein. Mag ja sinnvoll sein für ein Template,
dass man da irgendwie HTML reinschreibt. Also sprich, das hier ist das Beispiel von denen,
was Embedded war in einem Word Template. Also, warum sowas überhaupt erlaubt sein muss in
einem Word Template? Verstehe ich nicht. Ich meine, warum braucht man... Also, warum ist
JavaScript überhaupt erlaubt in einem Word Template? Warum kann man Word Sachen scripten
mit JavaScript, selbst wenn Makros deaktiviert sind? Was ist das für ein bescheuertes Design
von Microsoft wieder? Wo HTML ist, ist natürlich JavaScript auch nicht weit und das heißt,
man kann ein Word Template erstellen mit HTML drin und in diesem HTML ist dann JavaScript
drin. Es ist quasi, könnte man sagen, eine Webseite als Template. So, und bei dieser Kombination,
ja, da kommt es jetzt natürlich so, wie es kommen muss. Der JavaScript...
Übrigens, was ich in dem Video nicht zeige, ist, das hier ist Base64 encoded, das Power
Shell gedönnt, was dann versucht, irgendwelche RAR-Files zu entpacken. Das war jetzt aber
nicht wirklich relevant für das Video. Wie es kommen muss, der JavaScript im HTML Word
Template führt mit einem Trick am Ende Power Shell Befehle aus. Wir können uns das Ganze
mal kurz angucken, was da so drin steht. Ich zeige euch mal das Bild. Das ist jetzt vielleicht
auf den ersten Blick nicht so super verständlich. Zumindest, was hier dran interessant ist, dass
die Window Location geändert wird. Die Window Location ist in JavaScript quasi das, was
in eurem Browser die Adressleiste ist. Wenn das habe ich ganz gut erklärt mit der Adressleiste,
ich meine, praktisch gesehen stimmt es nicht wirklich, aber das ist das, was die meisten
Leute sich darin vorstellen können. Dort, wo ihr Seiten rein tippt, die ihr aufrufen
wollt. Man beachte hier an der Stelle auch, dass da am Anfang steht MS-MSDT-Doppelpunkt.
Also normal schreibt man ja im Browser...
Weiterbei, hier habe ich geschnitten. Ich habe in der Ursprungsaufnahme gesagt MS-MSDT-Doppelpunkt-Doppelslash.
Dann ist mir aufgefallen, das ist ja gar kein Doppelslash.
Mittlerweile muss man es nicht mehr schreiben, aber man würde sowas normalerweise hinschreiben
im Browser HTTP-Doppelpunkt-Doppelslash-Google.de oder sowas. In dem Fall könnte man sagen,
wird hier eine MS-MSDT-Seite aufgerufen. Also es wird nicht HTTP als Protokoll verwendet,
sondern MS-MSDT als Protokoll verwendet. Das wird die Sache noch deutlich schlimmer machen,
denn dahinter verbirgt sich ein Windows-Tool von Microsoft.
Gibt es den Base64-Text auch zum Copy... ja. Achso, nee. Die haben nur ein Bild. Die haben nur ein Bild hier drinnen irgendwo.
Hier glaube ich. Guck mal.
Das hier. Ja, kannst du aber nicht copypasten.
Das ist der decodete PowerShell-Befehl. Also sprich, das Base64 ist das hier.
Das versucht, irgendwelche RAR-Files zu decoden oder zu entpacken und sowas.
Komisches, komisches großen Zeugs. Hacker, Hacker-Man-Zeugs.
MSDT, das ist wohl der... es gibt leider ein paar doppeldeutige Abkürzungen bei Windows.
In dem Fall ist es wohl das Microsoft Support Diagnostic Tool.
Übrigens, ich habe keine Ahnung, warum das überhaupt Bestandteil ist und ich habe keine Ahnung, was das macht.
Was auch immer man damit genau macht. Ich habe mir nur zusammengereim, dass das wohl dieser Fehler Wizard sein muss.
Kennt ihr diesen Wizard? Windows, Wizard, Error, Troubleshoot, Troubleshooting Wizard.
Ja, diese Soundprobleme beheben. Genau.
Dieser Crap muss das irgendwie damit zu tun haben.
Dieser Troubleshooting Wizard. Reime ich mir so zusammen.
Wichtig an der Stelle ist, dass es ein offizielles Tool ist, das von Windows mitgeliefert wird, von Microsoft.
Das heißt, wenn das aufgerufen wird, wird kaum ein Antivirus herkommen und sagen, das ist problematisch.
Da wird MSDT aufgerufen. Nein, das ist ein offizieller Bestandteil.
Okay, an der Stelle könnten aktuell wirklich Antiviren-Software ansetzen und einfach mal alles, was MSDT ist und aufrufen will, plocken.
Weil 99% dürfte kein gewollter Aufruf sein aktuell.
Von Windows. Das heißt, da wird kein Virenscanner anschlagen und Windows-Defender fliegt.
Also sollen sie es doch blacklisten und irgendeinen Admin, der den Shit wirklich verwenden will, soll es dann whitelisten.
Das ist an der Stelle auch nicht an. Das heißt, man schafft es jetzt mit diesem manipulierten Java, mit diesem Template, mit dem manipulierten JavaScript-Inhalt im MSDT aufzurufen.
Das ist schon mal blöd, dass sowas überhaupt möglich ist.
Aber wir sind noch nicht bei PowerShell angelangt. So einfach ist es noch nicht.
Und über dieses MSDT-Tool kann man jetzt mit Geschick...
Von KS, Alter.
Ich glaube, ich hätte an der Stelle ein paar Pfeile machen sollen, wo man gucken muss.
Man muss nämlich hier gucken, dass es MSDT ist, und man muss hier gucken, dass es diese IT-Rebrowse-for-File-Zeugs-Parameter-Kram gesetzt hat.
Mit der Auswahl der Startparameter, vor allem ist es wohl IT underscore rebrowse for file, kann man MSDT Excel dazu benutzen, dass das wiederum PowerShell aufruft.
Und das Ganze, wenn man das mit den richtigen Startparametern macht, ohne dass ein Fenster aufploppt oder ohne...
Das habe ich gut übergeplendet, oder? In dem Moment, wo Fenster kommt, startet der Windows-Trailer.
Das ist tatsächlich Absicht an der Stelle gewesen.
Aktuell sind wir so, sind wir an der Stelle, du bekommst ein Dokument, ein Word-Dokument, klickst noch, sind wir beim Anklicken.
Du klickst das an, der lädt im Hintergrund von irgendwo auf der Welt ein Template runter mit HTML drin, in dem JavaScript drin ist,
das dann wiederum MSDT.exe startet, das dann wiederum PowerShell aufruft mit quasi, ja, beliebigem Inhalt.
Ja, das ist ja klar. Also sobald, sobald das irgendeiner geschafft hat, bei euch und auch nur im User-Kontext eine PowerShell zu starten,
da hat er erstmal gewonnen. Weil, damit kannst du alles machen.
Nicht der Rechner offen. Für so ziemlich alles. Aber du kannst in PowerShell nahezu alles machen, was man so machen kann.
Das Einzige, was an der Stelle vielleicht ein noch so ein bisschen rettet, ist, dass MSDT nicht mit Admin-Rechten läuft.
Das heißt, erstmal... Aber du hast so viele Möglichkeiten, du wirst über kurz oder lange Admin-Berechtigung auf dem System kriegen.
Und sei es nur, dass du irgendwie was nachlädst, was so einen UAC-Dialog faked oder... Es gibt tausend Möglichkeiten.
Also wenn du die, wenn du das Einfallstor offen hast und da PowerShell laufen hast, kannst dir jeder, du machst dir da irgendeinen Reverse-Shell auf,
dass du dich immer drauf connecten kannst und... Also, da hast du gelitten.
Du kannst ja auch Autostartsachen machen, geht ja auch als normaler Benutzer.
Und das ist gelaufen. Also im Prinzip... Im Prinzip kannst du dein Rechner formatieren.
Und das Schlimme ist halt, selbst wenn du keine Admin-Berechtigung hast, ich meine, die wichtigen Daten haben die Leute doch auf ihrem eigenen Windows-Account.
Also User-Account im Arsch. Das ist nur schwacher Trost.
Was aber ziemlich wurscht ist, weil ihr wahrscheinlich private Files und wichtige Sachen eh unter eurem Windows, unter eurem normalen Windows User-Account abgelegt habt.
Ja, die wenigsten Leute switchen erst auf den zweiten Windows-Account, um Word-Dokumente aufzumachen oder sowas.
Die Leute arbeiten unter ihrem normalen Windows-Account.
Oder ja, vielleicht ist man auch gleich Teil eines DDoS-Botnetzes...
Chet, dazu muss ich was sagen.
Oh Mist.
Muss ich mal stehen?
Ohne, dass ein Fenster aufploppt oder nur euer User-Account im Arsch.
.exe startet.
Muss ich mal stehen geblieben.
.powershell aufruft.
.file.
Hier, oder?
Hintergrund von irgendwo auf der Welt.
Template runter, mit HTML drin, in dem Jahr.
Ja, irgendwo hier.
Ich wollte aber schnell was zum Chats sagen und zwar...
Es ist ein Irrglaube, dass Open Source bug-freier oder besser ist.
Ja, das muss nicht zwangsläufig so sein.
Das stimmt schon.
Für mich ist ein Riesenvorteil davon, dass ich deutlich mehr Vertrauen habe in ein Open Source Projekt,
wenn ich es bei mir mit sensitiven Sachen laufen lasse, als irgendeinem Closed-Source-Campel.
Weil ganz im Ernst, wer würde, oder was würdest du nehmen als Passwortmanager?
Würdest du ein Open Source Passwortmanager nehmen?
Oder würdest du irgendeinen Cloud-Source...
Ja, noch schlimmer.
Cloud-based, proprietärer Cloud-based Passwortmanager nehmen?
Oder würdest du irgendwas nehmen, was 50.000 GitHub-Sterne hat?
Also reichen aus dem Gesichtspunkt...
Ja klar kann man nicht sagen, dass das automatisch besser ist.
Ist es nicht?
Ja, die meisten Open Source-Dinger sind auch teilweise richtig im Arsch.
Wenn du dir das ganze mit Log4j und das Gedöns anguckst, ist da mega kaputt.
Aber das ist für mich ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Letztens war auch irgendwas...
Ich hab...
Irgendeine richtig coole...
Obsidian war das, glaub ich.
Kennt das jemand?
Das ist so ein Notizprogramm.
Hab ich mir angeguckt und dachte, das ist doch richtig cool.
Und dann hab ich festgestellt, es ist keine Open Source.
Und deswegen benutze ich das nicht.
Es gibt wirklich Leute, die gucken danach.
Gerade ein Notizprogramm, wo ich wirklich vertrauenswürdige Sachen reinschreibe...
Und bestimmt auch mal kurzzeitig das eine oder andere Passwort reincopypaste...
Das will ich Open Source haben.
Ich will, dass der Kram...
Dass ich mir im Zweifelsfall auch drüber gucken kann.
Und das mache ich bei mancher Software tatsächlich.
Ich meine, gut, das kann nicht jeder Nupe-Benutzer machen.
Aber ich will, dass das ein Open Source Projekt ist.
Natürlich hast du noch ganz andere Probleme dann.
Ist halt die Frage...
Okay, die Quelle, von wo du es downloadest, vertraust du der Quelle...
Dass das, was du auf GitHub siehst...
Also das, was du dir auf GitHub als Source-Code anguckst...
Das, was du dir runterlädst, dass das wirklich das Gleiche ist.
Das ist oftmals gar nicht so einfach.
Wer überprüft denn irgendwelche Hash-Werte nach dem Download und so?
Also das ist wieder was anderes.
Nee, aber prinzipiell gebe ich dir an der Stelle recht...
Es muss nicht zwangsläufig bugfrei und besser sein.
Aber zumindest der Vertrauensaspekt und wenn das wirklich große Projekte sind...
Da kannst du zumindest mal davon ausgehen...
Dass mein Ikea-Sensor blinkt.
Der Windrückning-Ikea-Sensor blinkt gerade komisch.
Heißt, dass ich hier so hohe Feinstaubkonzentrationen habe, dass es langsam gefährlich wird.
Das wollte ich jetzt sagen, dass bei so großen Open Source Projekten...
Da kannst du zumindest mal davon ausgehen, dass die grundsätzlich mal tun, was sie sollen.
Und auch der normale Betrieb so weit bugfrei möglich ist, weil sonst hätten die keine 50.000 Sterne bekommen.
Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt irgendeine Library nehme von GitHub, mit der ich...
Nimm FFmpeg oder so oder...
Oder nimm React oder Vue.js oder sowas.
Wenn ich sowas nehme, dann kann ich davon ausgehen, dass die Basic Funktionalität...
Also das, was quasi tausende Benutzer verwenden von dieser Library...
Dass das in der Regel ganz passabel funktionieren würde, weil sonst hätten die keine 50.000 GitHub Sterne.
Also ein gewisser...
Ich weiß nicht, wie soll ich sagen.
So ein gewisser Qualitätsindikator, finde ich, ist das schon.
Ob es ein großes, bekanntes Open Source Projekt ist.
Ob das jetzt aus Security-Sicht wirklich besser und bugfrei ist, das ist natürlich was anderes.
Das kann man so nicht sagen.
Dafür gibt es viel zu wenige Leute, die die Sachen auch daraufhin analysieren und auch Ahnung davon haben.
Das kann man nicht sagen.
Das ist natürlich was anderes.
Kennst du White Source?
Also ich hab den Begriff schon mal gehört.
Selbst kann ich mir jetzt wenig darunter vorstellen.
Also du kannst natürlich eins, zwei Sätze in den Chat schreiben, dass du uns quasi erhältst, was man da genau darunter versteht.
Weil ich muss jetzt erstmal...
Max wird kein Apple-Fan.
Ich hab ein iPhone.
Tja, ich hätte wahrscheinlich privat auch kein iPhone.
Ich hab ein iPhone aus dem einzigen Grund, weil ich das nicht bezahlen muss.
Und...
Tja, warum sollte ich nochmal 600, 700 Euro für ein Smartphone ausgeben?
Ja, aber was den Punkt angeht, ist Smartphone eines der kritischsten Dinger.
Du hast gerade bei App Store Produkten...
Ich rede jetzt mal gar nicht von dem, dass der Betriebssystemhersteller selbst alles mit deinen Daten und mit dir machen kann.
Weil da hast du ja gar keinen Einfluss drauf.
Dir gehört das Gerät zwar offiziell, aber du hast ja keinen Einfluss drauf, was Android oder iOS da so wirklich machen.
Und du weißt das nicht.
Und...
Was ich viel schlimmer finde, auch wegen Open Source, ja, ist so.
Was ich viel schlimmer finde, ist, dass du dir auch bei App Store Produkten nicht so wirklich sicher sein kannst.
Ja, die App Store Sachen werden reviewed.
Potenziell härter im Apple App Store als im Android App Store.
Aber es gab genug Beispiele für...
Das ist ein bisschen wie mit Browser Addons zum Beispiel, ja.
Es gibt genug Beispiele, wo Leute sehr, sehr fragwürdige Dinge in ihren Apps drin hatten.
Und da bei den Apps hast du halt, bei App Store Käufen, du hast halt keine, du hast gar keine Chance dir das anzugucken.
Bei Android noch ein bisschen mehr.
Android kannst du dir meistens die APKs runterladen.
Und Android Anwendungen sind in der Regel relativ easy zu entpacken, die APKs, wenn man das wirklich machen will.
Wenn es Java ist, dann lässt sich Java ziemlich einfach decompilen.
Und wenn es normale APKs sind mit irgendwelchen Web-Anwendungen, also irgendwelche modernen Web-Anwendungen, dann erst recht.
Aber das macht ja keiner. Und unter iOS ist es noch schwieriger.
Dieter Ross, danke für den Sub. Nido, danke schön für den Sub.
So, wir gucken uns jetzt das Video endlich fertig.
Mein eigenes Null.
So, gleich geschafft.
Java Script drinne ist, dass dann wiederum msdt.exe startet.
Dass es dann wiederum PowerShell aufruft mit quasi, ja, beliebigem Inhalt.
Und damit ist natürlich der Rechner offen.
Oh Mist.
Du kannst den PowerShell nachher so alles machen.
Ich hab dich gebannt. Ich wollte dich nicht bannen. Ich wollte mit dem Message einigen.
Chat. Chat, Moment. Ich muss dich entbannen.
Der Ritter Ross war das. Den wollte ich nicht bannen.
Alter.
Äh. Moment.
Anbann.
Das ist ja auch kacke, dass da nicht nachgefragt wird, Alter.
So, aufkommen.
Hat er mich subscribt und direkt und direkt gebannt.
Null, Alter.
Das muss...
Ich hoffe, du bist noch da, Alter.
Nee.
Ich wollte die Nachricht...
Das ist aber auch dumm, dass dieses Banz, dieses permanent Banz-Symbol einfach direkt neben dran ist,
ohne dass eine Rückfrage kommt.
Und anscheinend hab ich noch jemand anderes angeklickt, weil er sagt,
deine Sperraktion steht im Konflikt mit einer anderen Sperraktion.
Also wahrscheinlich, wir hatten unten drunter gepostet.
Äh, TrappedOxygen hat drunter gepostet. Du hast Glück gehabt.
Twitter hat aus Versehen, äh, Twitch hat aus Versehen die Sperraktion nicht angenommen.
So ein bisschen rettet es, dass MSDT nicht mit Admin-Rechten läuft.
Nee, der Sub ist nicht weg.
Du kannst aber deinen Sub kündigen mit der Begründung, dich hat der Typ gebannt.
Das geht.
Erstmal ist nur euer User-Account im Arsch.
Was aber ziemlich wurscht ist, weil ihr wahrscheinlich private Files und wichtige Sachen eh unter eurem Windows,
unter eurem normalen Windows User-Account abgelegt habt.
Genau.
Deswegen ist es eigentlich egal.
Die wenigsten Leute switchen erst auf einen zweiten Windows-Account, um Word-Dokumente aufzumachen.
Richtig.
Die Leute arbeiten unter ihrem normalen Windows-Account.
Ich find's immer gut, wenn ich eigene Videos von mir gucke, gebe ich mir immer recht.
Aber wäre ja auch komisch, wenn nicht.
Oder vielleicht ist man auch gleich Teil eines DDoS-Botnetzes.
Nein, dafür braucht man auch nicht unbedingt Admin-Rechte.
Und wer weiß, sobald es mal wieder ein Admin-Exploit für Windows gibt,
kommt hier ab und zu auch mal vor,
steht quasi der weißrussische Hacker-Man quasi schon direkt in eurer Wohnung.
Also kannst du eigentlich von ausgehen, der Rechner ist versaut, du musst neu installieren.
Und du musst theoretisch auch davon ausgehen, dass der Files abgezogen hat.
In der Praxis wirst du wahrscheinlich Glück haben, weil es kein gezielter Angriff gegen dich sein wird.
Und wahrscheinlich erst mal nichts.
Aber man weiß es nicht.
Eurem Rechner und kann weitermachen.
Das ist natürlich nicht schön.
Aber ich hab doch am Anfang irgendwas gesagt mit...
Jetzt kommt der Hammer, ja.
Der Teil muss nicht mal angeklickt werden.
Oder vielleicht, wenn ich mir so richtig überlege,
vielleicht schreibe ich das sogar ins...
Was?
Wenn ich mir so richtig überlege...
Ja, manchmal...
Das Problem hab ich ja im Stream auch.
Manchmal fang ich an zu reden, bevor ich in meinem Hirn den Satz gedacht habe.
Ja, es wird noch besser.
Wenn die Datei nämlich nicht als Word-Dokument im Doc-Format bei euch ankommt,
sondern als RTF, dann reicht es, wenn...
By the way, RTF ist dieses Rich Text Format,
was beispielsweise auch WordPad verwendet und sowas.
Aber WordPad ist nicht betroffen, weil die machen keine Word-Dokumentenvorlagen.
Man einen Windows Explorer öffnet mit dem Ordner, wo die Datei drinnen liegt.
Also zum Beispiel ihr bekommt eine Webseite mit einem Link auf der Datei,
ihr ladet das runter und macht dann irgendwann mal...
Wer benutzt WordPad?
Ich frag mich, dass bei den meisten eingebauten Windows-Apps, wer diesen Kram verwendet.
Euren Download-Ordner auf.
Ich hab keine Antwort drauf.
Dann seid ihr auch gefickt.
Leute, ich hab gesagt, ihr seid auch gefickt,
und ich habe nicht bei YouTube angekreuzt Language.
Ich hätte Language ankreuzen müssen.
Wobei, da steht nur die erste Minute. Nur die erste Minute zählt.
Und das ist nach der ersten Minute.
Durch die Explorer-Vorschau-Funktion wird das Ganze dann aktiv.
Ohne, dass ihr Word öffnen müsst. Ohne, dass in die Datei...
Mir fällt das jetzt gerade aus.
Guckt euch mal dieses Hintergrundvideo an.
Explorer-Vorschau-Funktion.
Ohne zuzuhören. Guckt euch mal das an.
Was zum Teufel?
Ach, das ist TikTok.
Okay, dann ist alles klar, was da abgeht.
Ohne, dass ihr Word öffnen müsst. Ohne, dass in die Datei anklicken müsst.
Da ist man sich noch ein bisschen unsicher,
in welcher Kombination das genau funktioniert.
Von Windows, von Word, aber...
Also sprich, nur mal, falls ihr mitgekriegt habt.
Also es kann sein, wenn ihr ein RTF-Dokument runterladet
und dann den Ordner öffnet.
Zum Beispiel den Download-Ordner, wo das drin ist.
Und ihr File-Vorschau anhabt.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das Anzeigen von diesen Sachen hier schon reicht.
Dann seid ihr auch gefickt.
Das Beste ist einfach, kein Word installiert haben.
Wenn ihr Pech habt, funktioniert das.
Und das ist natürlich heftig.
Ich habe ja schon oft in Videos gesagt,
es ist nicht so sehr das Problem,
einen Virus auf dem Internet öffnen zu bekommen,
sondern eher, dass der auch ausgeführt wird und aktiv wird.
Das ist damit natürlich easy möglich.
Das heißt, jeder mit installiertem Word
sollte sich nur mal Gedanken machen,
was er für Dokumente in letzter Zeit bekommen hat.
Zumal es schon viele Beispiele gibt, wo das auch ausgenutzt wird.
Da wollte ich was zu sagen.
Mittlerweile, jetzt ein paar Stunden, nachdem ich das Video hochgeladen habe,
es gibt immer mehr Beispiele, dass das ausgenutzt wird.
Gerade vorhin kam sogar ein Post nochmal bei Heise.
Du musst den Ordner einklicken und ihn aufmachen,
was du ja machst, wenn du hier draufklickst.
Wenn es hier drinnen liegt, in Downloads.
Ja, sogar Heise hat vorhin einen Artikel gepostet da drüber
mit irgendwelcher hier da hier.
Alert!
Wenn sogar Heise da schon was drüber postet,
dann ist das wirklich sehr relevant.
...
Ergibt es konkrete Handlungsempfehlungen?
Ja, je nachdem.
Man kann über irgendeine Gruppenrichtlinie für seine Clients abschalten lassen,
dass das überhaupt soweit kommt.
Sprich, dass dieses Protokoll hier aktiv ist.
Dieses MS-MSDT.
Die eigentliche Word-Sicherheitslücke kannst du damit nicht abschalten.
Aber du kannst halt, dass diese Sache in dieser Form ausgenutzt werden kann, abschalten.
Das kannst du selbst bei Registry abschalten.
Und angeblich ist wohl auch irgendein Windows-Patch schon in der Mache unterwegs.
Hab ich irgendwo nebenbei aufgeschnappt.
Aber Microsoft selbst ist da nicht so scharf drauf, was dran zu ändern.
Weil für die ist ja Remote Templates ein tolles Feature, was da bleiben soll.
Warum man nicht einfach sagt, man macht es standardmäßig aus, verstehe ich nicht.
Weil ganz ehrlich, eigentlich ist das ein Feature, was man standardmäßig wirklich nicht haben will.
Es gibt einen inoffiziellen Preview-Patch nach Geil.
Also das Beste aktuell tatsächlich ist Word deinstallieren und was anderes verwenden.
Oder macht so wie ich, verwendet gar keine Office-Produkte.
Ich meine, ich glaube, ich habe LibreOffice oder hier drauf, ja.
Hab ich Word drauf? Nö.
Was ist das?
Irgendwas vorinstalliertes ist das.
Aber ich verwende keine Textverarbeitung.
Weder LibreOffice noch Word.
Und auch kein PowerPoint und sowas.
Textverarbeitung verwende ich zu 90% Texteditor mit Markdown.
Und Excel, ja. Ganz ehrlich, ihr kennt meine Meinung zu Excel.
Ich denke, Excel ist das einzige Programm im gesamten Office.
Also von den Basics-Sachen, was irgendwie eine Daseinsberechtigung hat.
Excel ist quasi die IDE des BWLers oder die IDE der Hausfrau.
Darf man das, der Hauspersonen, der Hausmenschen, der Haus...
Ja, sag mal, gibt es eigentlich auch eine Männlichkeitsform,
wenn man standardmäßig Hausfrau sagt?
So, man sagt dann HandwerkerInnen.
Gibt es dann auch eine Vermännlichung oder sowas dann?
Also ja, im Moment Hausmann. Hausmann trifft es ja auch nicht.
Also irgendwas, wo man dann aus Hausfrau oder Haus irgendwie dann noch beide einschließt.
Ohne, dass man sich ein eigenes Wort ausdenken muss.
Hauswirtschafter. Ah ja, das ist natürlich nicht schlecht.
Hauswirtschaftende. Das wäre es, oder?
Das ist die Pfeifert-Sache, die heute...
Hauswirtschaftende. Das ist komplett neutral.
Ergibt wenig Sinn, weil das mehrdeutig ist.
Es könnten ja auch Leute sein, die im Haus wirtschaftende sind.
Aber egal, das ist ein unsinniges Thema.
Ja, jetzt haben wir uns das Video nochmal angeguckt.
Ich konnte ein paar Takte dazu loswerden.
Haushaltsführende Person. Aha, siehst du mal.
Find ich toll, dass es da sogar schon Seiten für gibt.
Haushaltsführende Person.
Das kann aber auch was anderes mit gemeint sein.
Mit Haushaltsführend kann man auch... Also es kommt auf den Kontext an.
Also es ist nicht so einfach.
Okay Leute, ich bin jetzt schon 25 Minuten über Bett getimed.
Ich gehe jetzt auch pennen. Wir sehen uns.
Spontaner Stream heute gewesen. Im nächsten wird er gebastelt.
Also bis denn. Macht's gut. Bis zum nächsten Stream.